what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
[Applause]
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it drop a like on the video
and sign up for our memberships to see
exclusive behind the scenes
content before i start we need to
introduce our lovely guests today so
everybody go around say your name your
age your relationship status and where
you're from when do you start cool hi
everyone my name is tais i'm 23 and i'm
single as a pringle not ready to mingle
hi everybody my name is evangeline i'm
24 and i'm single and y'all believe me
alone i'm not dating anyone
hi i'm zoe anna i am 22 and i am
currently dating
[Music]
hi i'm tegan i'm 20 and i'm single
hello i'm thank him
i am 26 i'm from london and i'm single
as well
hi my name is lj halsey and i'm 27 i'm
from london and i'm single okay so the
topic today
is
should modern women settle
so are you guys aware of the 80 20 rule
when it comes to dating
no no so i think you guys you're more
familiar with the content you might
right yes okay so if you ask 80 of women
what they look for in a guy they list
out 20 of men sometimes less so the
reason a lot of times girls will say
things like men or trash men are the
worst is because
um they're all sleeping with the same
ones
they say that 20 of men have sexual
access to 80 of women
yeah so um and there there's numbers
that back this up like for example men
swipe right on tinder 46 of the time
and
what percent of the time do you think
women swipe right on tinder
i think that's why i'm left
no i i know so what percent of the time
as a girl
percentage of that i think like yeah
half of that twenty-five percent you
think yeah
maybe five five percent five
so there's a bunch there's a bunch of
different studies and different ones
will say different things but the the
most recent one i found is women swipe
right 14 of the time oh but i i have
seen it as low as five before because
when you think about it that's just them
swiping right that doesn't include like
what percent do they go on a date with
that's true okay right right so the
question is
oh and then on top of that sorry second
part
is um half of women over 30 are single
and childless
so knowing what we know right there's
not enough men to go around that the
women want
so my question is should women settle
hell no no
okay no no why do you guys why
i mean
in this day and age especially as
dancers as for us
no having a kid
kind of halts your dance career yeah and
and
because like and that to me and all of
that stuff for guys they can do whatever
the hell they want you know they can
do everything and then their babies look
right
they don't have to worry about speaking
to the mike speaker not deal with the
consequences but um
but as women we don't get that privilege
so
well what does the biological clock have
to do with settling i just don't
understand that
i think
well
for women settling is having kids
getting married having a family right
yeah and so in order to do all of that
mainly i'm thinking about the family
thing
we
once you have a family we have to
provide for that child for the whole
their whole lives whereas
men don't really have to do that they
can do what they want and then leave
no not well they're on the hook for
child support for 18 years
if they want to pay yeah if you want to
pay it well you can't you can go to jail
if you don't pay child support
i'm sorry may i say um
i found it interesting that you read the
question as should women settle down as
in get married have children and have a
life with a partner
i thought the question was around should
women settle for a man that they
believed to be less valuable than they
themselves are yeah
that's how i was yeah that's how i
started but hold on if i may just say
i'm astonished that you would say
that women should not settle down and
get married and have children in general
that to me i find perplexing i'm saying
as a dancer as a dancer okay
but is that not something that is
something that would give the vast
majority of women
including dancers some sense of purpose
i think some sense i think
i think in terms of dances it would
literally stop our whole career because
even say like we have
like 35 shows going on like whatever
like in our in our calendar or our
schedule if that happens
she won't really
i understand but the careers of athletes
as as as similar for dancers is limited
how long are you going to be how long
are you going to be dancing for as long
as i can as long as as long as you can
and i wish you you know good luck with
that but at the end of that
do you consider like having children
having a partner oh 100. yeah i think it
depends when we want to stop like if i
have a kid and i feel like that's the
right time then obviously then i'm like
oh i'm ready to start a family and i'm
ready to do what i can but if it's in
the wrong time if it's really unexpected
then like it's really it's a shock you
know what i'm saying so
during that time i would have no choice
then to
have my child and i'll have to maybe
give up my career are you all dancers
yeah okay okay um i'm interested to know
as to whether you think that it's best
to perhaps settle down after
your career as dancers
because
at what age would that career end is it
in your early 30s is it in your late 30s
perhaps in your 40s oh basically my six
days i sincerely hope that that's the
case for you too
but if you're thinking that you want to
get married at the end of your career
i'm sure you don't want to get married
at 60 you might want to get married a
little bit earlier yeah did you know 90
of your eggs are gone by 30
90
and did you know that geriatric
pregnancy starts at 35
and even if you do ivf do you do you
know how much that costs if you want to
do ivf yeah
it's 25k goodness me and that may not
even work
so so why do you think we tell women to
prioritize like why would you tell girls
to prioritize a career over a family
when if you wait too long to have a
family then you can't have one
i mean
for me personally i feel like it's
completely up to the person yeah but for
me personally i'm not even sure if i
want kids i don't know i don't want to
get married i do want to have a partner
and i'd like to live with them but
for me yeah i prioritize my career
because i've never been in a
relationship it's
never really worked out for me so i
don't see why that needs to be a
priority for me
maybe if i'd been in a relationship
before maybe i would see that as more of
a path but
my upbringing and the way my life has
gone that is not a priority for me my
career is because that's where i can put
all my energy
and my effort but i would never say to
someone
um you have to have children before 30
or you have to have children after 30
you have to prioritize your creates
completely up to you no i agree i think
people should choose what they want to
choose but we should be aware of the
so single single childless women over
the age of 45 are statistically the
least happy
is that really a shock though is that a
shock like i mean you think about it you
can't undo our biology so as much as
like you know the times have changed
like our biology still makes us want to
have children
so i i think
a lot of times girls prioritize their
their career when they're young and they
don't realize it they they might not
have the option to have a partner or a
children later
yeah it's true i feel like it just
depends on the person and
if they want to go down that path
because
once you get a partner it's like it's a
commitment as well so this is like okay
cool enough to juggle two things
at the same time which is probably why
they
like don't want to
have a relationship during their career
yeah but
yeah but going on what you said i've
seen a lot of dancers like not a lot let
me chill
like i've seen i've seen some dancers
and choreographers have like
kids and they've obviously taken a break
but then they will always come back yeah
yeah i don't see nothing wrong with just
taking a break in your career if that's
the case if you do have a partner yeah i
think if a break and come back to the
type of thing yeah spend time with your
family yeah and like janet jackson oh
she's a queen of pop obviously and she
had a kid like that's that's different
but i think still as a dancer in in the
industry i think you still have a child
and still do both like why can't you do
both
you know well i think it's just that
everything comes at a cost
yeah so so if you take a break like
you're not gonna out compete the girls
that didn't yeah yeah and so it's gonna
it's going to affect your career but if
you don't prioritize family you might
not be able to have one later yeah so
it's kind of like a double edge you
can't have everything
um so question for you guys do you guys
have um a height requirement that you
have to date a guy no i do now you do
okay so go around like tell me what your
minimum standards are to date a guy
like what you look for i wouldn't have a
height requirement but i would prefer to
be with a guy that's taller than me or
at least my height okay which is
i'm five eight okay high vader taller
okay
yeah i i agree but then i end up getting
dating guys who are eye level yeah same
and then it's like um no you're
disrespectful so i prefer to date a guy
who's taller than me yeah
are there any other standards like money
requirements or no you don't care about
money no
um
i don't mind actually i've actually
spoken to people my height or like a bit
shorter
but um
yeah i don't mind the height
and
what else do i like
what are the standards
let's turn out let's come
but they're the ones who i live without
the most disrespectful ones
i'm sorry
the ones have the most
vim to say and it's like is that the
minute
the minute the minute i speak active the
minute i speak i'm crazy
is it that you find
uh a taller brother that might be
showing the same kind of mad behavior
you don't you'll accept that from a
taller guy no i didn't say that
nobody
is that what the case is so no no no so
from from me from what i've come across
the guys shorter men are more
disrespectful oh of course
[Laughter]
but the guys who have come across you
are taller than me they have
i don't know i don't know what it is but
they just have more respect and that's
the ones who i've come across and
they they i think they know their
boundaries with some women okay you know
why do you think that is like the taller
guys in your experience are like more
respectful or kinder or what do you what
do you think it is the difference
between the shorter men and the i think
they've i think i've spent more time
with them not that i haven't spent more
time with the ones who are high level
but i feel like they don't understand
and they don't limit their boundaries
with what with sometimes with what they
say okay because i feel like sometimes
with what like with what guys say they
don't really care even though they're
seeing that woman and it's like oh oh
like oh she should know she should know
i'm joking she should know this and she
should know that and it's like no and
it's like the tall guys that i've seen
like for me personally
they already like
set a boundary with me and them so they
should know what to say when not to say
it like they're not disrespectful do you
know what i mean don't get wrong some
two guys are just some two guys listen
oh yeah true true
it's just that some men are
disrespectful
yeah i feel like yeah i feel like i feel
like it's mixed anyway i feel like
it just depends who it is one thing one
thing i will say to you over here one
thing i'll say to you is i think your
disparity is more so that
you don't respect the short guys and
therefore you'll find that when they say
something rude to you it's like who the
hell are you to speak to me
as a tall guy
which may be your type as such if he's
disrespectful oh he's putting me in my
place i understand where god is
how can you tell me
all short guys are disrespectful and you
find that most tall guys are not there
but then she said don't get twisted
which i agree on because some because
some men anyway some in any way are
disrespectful anyway so this is what i'm
saying like i i haven't really dated as
much like
when you sometimes when you talk to like
like different sort of guys like they
can come across as like the same someone
can come some of them can come across as
different so it just depends that's what
i'm saying it just depends on who the
guy is i'm not saying oh shot man i just
level do you know what i mean but yeah
just depends who they are it just really
depends who they are what percent of men
do you think are six foot and taller
okay this is a hot one in the uk or the
uk yeah or in the world um
actually i don't know i think it's i
think it's in the in the world oh that's
a lot then 25
yeah do you think i don't really think
it's that less i don't know you know i
think it's so i think it's tight i think
it's 50. 50. i think it's 50. i think
it's 15.
okay wait one at a time so 50.
i was going to say 5 30. 30 it's 15
percent
oh
god for big bad things no no guys guys
so so it goes it goes back to it goes
back to what i was saying earlier the
reason women say things like men like if
a girl says men are trash men are trash
men are trash it typically means i've
been ran through by a bunch of guys that
didn't want me
oh yeah yeah that's true yeah and it's
like typically because only 15 of men
are six foot
so typically she's dating a guy that's
too hot for her and it's out of her
league and none of her friends are nice
enough to tell her you're screwing the
guy that's out of your league and maybe
you should get a guy on your level
because i will screw you but he'll never
wife you period period yeah i think i
agree with that but i think there's also
another thing for me to do feel as
though
uh whether you know there are plenty of
women out there who are virgins who have
never had experience or anything like
that that are running around saying men
are trash maybe they might have a bad
relationship with their dads or whatever
or maybe they've just heard from their
aunties or their sisters oh this is my
relationship with these terrible men out
here men are trash they've become
indoctrinated to it
but if they don't have a healthy
relationship with men then how do you
expect them to kind of
have any other view i don't know any
virgins that have that view that men are
trash every girl that i know that that
says that stuff
is just a girl that has been ran through
yeah like honestly like you know it's a
girl that's been ran through or she's
she's shooting too high and none of her
friends are nice enough to say hey
yeah that guy will see you like once a
week and screw you but he's never going
to be seen in public with you yeah is
there something about
you know that female dynamic where those
friends won't
is there a reason why those friends
weren't we're more agreeable than man
i'll tell you straight up i don't care
yeah we like to hype our friends up
yeah we like to support
we're like we don't really see it as no
i'm sorry i'm telling them yeah i would
yeah i would tell them obviously i would
tell them too but i don't we don't
really see it well i don't see it as
not a bad not not bad thing but like i'm
not trying to put them down yeah yeah
and make them feel well yeah but i think
there's a difference between putting
someone down and letting them live in
delusion that is true so so if i have a
friend that's like let's let's let's say
she's a five and that's not a bad thing
if you're five that means you're average
looking most people are average looking
so so i have a girl a friend that's a
five and she's constantly have
like sleeping with guys that are eights
nines and tens and she's constantly
getting her heart broken
like don't you think it's nicer to just
say hey maybe maybe date a little 100 a
little lower 100 percent and that's but
i feel like some context oh yes yeah so
yeah that's settling for a man then that
was my next yes yes
yes because you think and like in her
head she thinks that the guy wants her
because of like just because he's
sleeping with you and sometimes girls
don't really realize that no he just
wants to have sex with you
do you know what i mean wouldn't you
rather go for a man that you think wants
to marry you right of course
yeah i think that's an issue that's the
thing girls want yeah in the first place
and that's probably why sometimes
screwed because it's just like they have
a good image of the guy in first place
and it's just like okay
he's done me wrong the first time let me
give him another chance he's done around
the second time it's just like
you're always putting hope into that guy
so now i was just like like you said
when your friends are looking at you
like okay quite you see your the guy is
screwing you just like no he's calm like
these people are collecting red flags
though no honey
so that's just you settling from the
time he's screwing you and he's just
doing it over and over again you're
literally settling just for that
quick question
are you saying are you saying you're
settling for the guy just sleeping with
you yeah that's that link i feel like
that's certainly right
that is settling because that is that
all you're going to do mm-hmm
you're not going on dates you're not
meeting family you're not going out
you're not having fun but you're just in
my bedroom
they will act like they want you in the
beginning that's the thing that
sometimes sometimes girls actually don't
know
like even though you they did you don't
go on dates and all that stuff but then
they they don't realize that you're not
going on days they just like
in my experience i think guys tell you
pretty early what they want and girls
are just afraid to ask them what they're
looking for and because they're scared
of like scaring them away
but like when you ask a guy what you're
looking for in your upfront and honest
it seems like you get the best results
because then you get guys that are
actually on your level
yeah but like i don't find that most
guys are trying to deceive you early on
like i find that most guys that like
most of my friends that have ended up in
situation ships the guy said i'm not
looking for anything serious and she
agreed to it
and then three months later when she's
in love
she is awesome she she
loves she'll blame the guy even though
you you agreed yeah that that's her
thought though right yes 100 is because
he clearly said i don't want anything
okay cool but some guys don't say that
though
i'm sorry some guys actually act like
they're like you they take you out at
first it's true they compliment you
they're like right and then they get to
know you they get they
they get to know you a little bit and
then you remember like you said they
start screwing you from the time they
start screwing goose
escape
yeah but also sometimes i think those
guys maybe were interested to start but
the girl doesn't offer anything but but
sex so she thinks she's above like
cooking for a guy cleaning for a guy she
thinks she's above
making that guy's life better and so
then of course he's just gonna use you
for sex if you have nothing else to
offer but sex yeah
right yeah but obviously you're not
going to move in straight away it's
exactly cooking clean i mean i know
you're just using it
why not okay i have a question can't you
clean or cook
i want in this yard to be cleaning again
period you have to be after me
say if he came to your yard you know
would it be so okay but would it be
wrong to
cook him at dinner or whatever like
you know that's all right actually
i need to see that you're here forever
but i would consider that so you need
commitment before you do all of those
things is that what you're saying sorry
you need commitment before you show i
need to see that you're actually here
for a long time i'm not
going to be doing certain duties and
you're not here long time sorry but why
would he commit to you if he doesn't see
what he's gonna get exactly so why am i
gonna cook clean yeah all of this you're
not i'm not your mum sorry but why would
you then sleep with a man if you
wouldn't cook for him or clean for him
how'd you know i'm sleeping with him
sorry i am just assuming okay yeah yeah
yeah but you never know you never know
you never know like it just depends like
so at the level would would that mean
you'd be finessing him then no one's
like it out
you're answering questions with
questions so now i'll put that question
to you
but that's not i don't i don't really
see that as finishing i feel like it's
just a way of like
showing okay i'm interested in you i'm
seeing this as long term
so
if you're saying this as long term it
depends on what like how long it takes
to fall for that person and how long
that connection
gets stronger if i can see that you're
being serious about me then yes okay
cool i can cook for you i can come to
your house and whatever we can but what
if what if he says i won't spend money
on you until i see you're serious about
me what if i won't spend the money on
you what if what if the guy says i won't
spend money on you until i see you're
serious about me
no but i will show you yeah that's fine
on me i got my own money in the box
they're free yeah i was gonna yeah what
does it look like for a man to be
serious about you
good communication
yeah
honesty
um what else loyalty yeah loyalty
um sorry i'd say it's the same vice
versa yeah of course 100 100
i feel like it's like a 50 50 thing like
yeah i don't see his head
in your head
oh you're shaking your head i would hear
you okay
me personally i think it's like if
you're getting to know someone like i
think it's 50 50 because
like
i don't think it's always the guy that
needs to be doing this this this this
this
to show that they're interesting yes you
would like that we would like that as a
female but
like what she was saying if you he's if
he's not getting that at the same time
like it's almost a point how would how
would he know that i'm interested as
well
what because i'm seeing you every now
and then because you asked like
is that really going to show you're
interested
i don't think it's 50 50. i think we all
have our roles and responsibilities 100
so then just
that we have our roles and
responsibilities how can it ever be 50
50. if we go on a date
i'm taking you out i should be paying
don't get me wrong
don't get me wrong under the
relationship dynamics of like
if you're in a couple together then you
can have that discussion as to whether
what works for you guys but
i don't know fair enough no no sorry
but can i just ask you this then so if
you was dating
like before a relationship you wouldn't
let your girl like the person you're
talking to
like pay for a date
if she wanted to that's different i'll
take you out i think can i can i sorry
can i add on i think
like what you said like if you take a go
out you'll pay for for me personally
like if it was vice versa if i if i took
a guy out on a date i would pay because
i'm paying for his time and i'm like
that's what i'm asking you know what
would you not let a girl do that
but i think no i think that's different
because he asked the girl out he's the
one that's initiating
that he wants to take her do you know
what i mean like this is how it happens
i said this on the lasso or some show
ago if a girl
was to pay for me
to go out on a date yeah i'd be
questioning why she's paying for me like
and the reason why i'd say i was go
why is she trying to secure me like as a
man i should be able to pick my woman
right
girls should not be picking their men
and if they're doing the pick me thing
and they're like trying to get a man
what's wrong with her that's what i'm
questioning like why does she want me to
get her why is she trying to secure me
but what's wrong with that
maybe are you saying women shouldn't
choose their partners i'm saying guys
should choose their partners i'm saying
women should essentially throw out the
handkerchief to
let the man know that oh
i'm feeding you but men should make the
initial move to a woman well what time
or whatever time what if she what if you
was actually feeding her though like if
she was if she paid for your date and
like did stuff for you the times if you
paid for a man's date
how many times have you paid for him
i've only paid once and i cried how did
it go
how did it go it was a good day it was a
good day i mean did you see that man
again what the [ __ ] now
[Laughter]
can i say something can i say something
before y'all attack me
that was actually my first date ever oh
that's sweet oh so he done you died yeah
yeah
no he did he did he did i can go on
because
yeah yeah you not know who he is
yeah yeah you don't know who he is yeah
yeah you're probably watching this
yeah
no i paid and he actually went calm like
it was a talk yeah it was a calm date
but like obviously stuff happened and
like he i realized that he wasn't like i
wasn't the guilt that he was into it and
that's okay but it was in order for me
to learn because i didn't know anything
about dating relationships and like
anything back then so
it was enough so then you learned you
don't pay a holiday
no but there's nothing wrong with that
oh okay so one thing i will say to you
is yeah i know you may not see the
consequences of your actions by paying
for a date but word of advice from me
don't pay on the first date with a man
oh i know that now i'm not i'm never
paying for the first time
i thought we were talking about paying
for dates in general is that what we
were talking about yeah that's what i
was first i think we were just speaking
about
roles and yeah also than anything 5050 a
better example if a burglar comes into
the house
are we 50 50 defending each other
both in the house we're both in the
house
we have another example what if
for the draft should it be 50 50 50 men
50 percent women going to work
so if there's a war and they have to
draft people yeah you should it be 50
50. nope
you're going to say
i mean it depends what i'm gonna go to
the water depends on what we're doing
yeah i know i'm gonna have friends fight
like fighting come back
risk my life yeah but
she's not talking about one at a time
she's not talking about you either she's
talking about in general yeah what why
not
would you prefer if i
stayed at home and you guys went to
fight the wars for example you wouldn't
right or like in general i can't lie
when i said 50 50. i didn't mean like
every single thing yeah yeah yeah i
meant like certain things yeah yeah so
it should be selecting the quality
yeah
i know that sounds a bit more equality
though
a common complaint i hear from men is
that women only fight for equality when
it doesn't benefit us but we never want
any of the drawbacks
so for example we'll happily take the
free drinks the free dates and getting
into bars for free but if the rolls were
reversed we would throw a fit if the men
got into the bars for free and we had to
pay
that's just true that's true
it's mad but that's true
and we never hear women talk about um
like we hear about the pay gap but we
never talk about how men have the harder
jobs like plumbing electric
the building yeah
women do those jobs too no they don't
not statistics like less than two
percent in those industries they don't
but out of those women
how many of them are getting paid the
same as the men that do the exact same
thing that is true yeah how many
women get paid the same as men when you
take into account the number of hours
worked
and you take into account the industries
that they pick there's no pay gap it's
been debunked multiple times
okay
yeah i'd say nowadays it doesn't exist
because they've made the equal pay act
right which was introduced in the 70s
right
i think
i think yeah people who use that women
that use the argument nowadays they
clearly haven't done their research fair
enough i understand that
and i think we as women we do have
privilege in certain contexts and i do
think that's unfair personally and i do
think that should be addressed and i
think i i personally don't think about
that and i'm glad you brought that up
because i don't i don't consciously
think about that i don't get bought
drinks often a lot in clubs but if i do
i will take it and i'm not going to go
around buying a guy a drink personally i
wouldn't i'd be scared so i ain't taking
that thank you i wouldn't but after you
buy me that trick so you're all spiky
[Music]
looking at you all the time yeah i'm
like
that is a worry that is where it is yeah
it is where we are what were you saying
um no i was just saying i i see
your point there and that yeah in
certain contexts we do have privilege
and i get your point about the pay gap i
don't think that is really an issue
anymore but i do think in certain
industries like the plumbing and the
whatever else you said
um yeah there are a lot less
statistically women that are doing that
but i also think that
so we've been socialized to not want to
do them jobs and i still do think that
is an issue and i think that we should
have more
i know there are opportunities out there
but i just feel like they're not
advertised enough for us and they should
be pushed in things like secondary
schools and primary schools and they're
not so
why how can we say they're not pushed on
us when there are things like quotas for
women
so they don't even know what that is so
a quota a quota means basically that the
company says you have to hire this many
women so i'll give you an example my
brothers work in engineering and they
can't convince girls to do that job
like they they recruit girls all the
time and girls just don't want to do it
so
why do we assume it's society and maybe
not something innate in us
because if you to go to the country so
if you make a list of the countries from
the most egalitarian so like where women
have the most freedom to the least
freedom the pay graph it increases it
doesn't decrease
because uh when women have more choice
they pick jobs with people and men when
they have more choice they pick jobs
with things
and um
and so
like basically like and i i think that's
because it's something innate in us like
women i just think are because
historically we had to nurture children
like we just prefer people where men
just prefer things
can i add on this um because i'm
actually going into the teaching
profession in september i think that's
generally a profession that is dominated
by women
um you do need those interpersonal
skills those more kind of feminine soft
skills as they call it like those
interpersonal skills
to be able to engage with people teach
young children to be able to
safeguard them and if there's something
going on at home et cetera et cetera
um
but that now there is a need for more
men to be in the teaching profession in
these kinds of professions because
young kids
need more male role models around
basically i'm not saying i'm a role
model obviously but um
you're right like
you know there isn't this kind of
argument for example
where bricklayers are saying we need 50
women bricklayers you know this
disparity is terrible only fans models
we need to pay them the same
strippers
models
like oh like no one's riding because
kylie jenner out earns like every male
model
well i'm sure even another example if
we're going to talk about say for
pornography you know i'm sure
i'm sorry sorry
algorithm pornography yeah cornflakes
so if we're gonna you know look at the
paid disparity between the female
performers um and the male performers i
am 100 sure that the female performance
get more money uh but that's also an
industry that is
kind of
geared towards male a male audience who
are gonna who is obviously more likely
to pay for women than they are for men
but should we be fighting for our equal
pay for male corn flakes
etc i don't know i don't know if we
should i think you know chips fall where
they make no we definitely shouldn't
there's more things to worry about than
should men get paid equally on corn
i agree
um no i just i think it's more of like
what people like doing
and like a lot of people talk about the
like the two percent um like basically
that ceo ceos a very small percentage is
women and all the people in power
um but my my dad so he was he's in a top
one percent earner he's he's very
successful but the trade-off is you have
to work 80 hours a week for 30 years i i
don't know many girls that want to do
that i know i sure as hell
i would rather die than work 12 hour
days every day that sounds terrible
yeah yeah you see
i'm like i don't want it that bad but a
lot of times like we think it's because
something in society is holding us back
but it's just what people want to do
yeah what kind of personality traits did
your dad have to be that driven
eight hours a week every week
because
you know that's my not just a workhorse
like even he's retired now and he's
still he's just starting another company
like he can't rest right like there's
just certain guys like that
um but going back to the a little off
topic going back to the original
question of like should women settle
um do you for a question for the men and
ish i'm gonna you can be in this too do
you think most girls think that they're
hotter than they are
oh wow
for the for the man
i'll say this carefully um look i think
people in general have uh great
difficulty being objective about how
they look i think uh okay women you
think it's the men do you think no well
i think men less so to be honest with
you if i'm if i'm being i'm trying to be
as diplomatic as possible yeah but
look truthfully
i think men don't really have
uh the same kind of
uh problems with objectivity excuse me
like for example myself
if i were to you know like rate myself
or whatever i'd probably give myself
somewhere around like a four or a five
maybe even less depending on who's
observing the reason why i say that and
the reason why i say that's an objective
rating
we could take into consideration height
skin color ethnicity
uh
some people might like facial hair some
people don't i'm growing bold you know
it's happening my dad's bored you know
like that might take a couple of points
off for some people or it might increase
who knows but i've got to accept that
as a as a man yeah i've got to accept my
station the fact that maybe i was less
blessed genetically than others or more
blessed genetically than others or
whatever
and i've got to just do what i can to
improve i feel as though women
regardless of whether they're big small
tall
dark white whatever
there's a a sense of like
um
i deserve
some kind of like a high value man or a
high value partner or whatever like
hence why you were talking about the 820
rule why the majority vast majority of
women go for the same couple of dudes
yeah so there is a sense of entitlement
there
if you're all going for the same guys
not all of you are going to get the same
guys obviously so some of you guys need
to kind of
take stock and be like well maybe i'm
not cut out for that kind of guy
or whatever you know let me find someone
in my station in my wheelhouse in my
category
so what about you what do you think the
only thing i'd add is um why do girls
think all their friends are hot
all
yeah i just think that's uh that's uh
evidence that girls don't think judge
themselves accordingly to how they look
i do um could you answer could you ask
the question again so the question is do
you think most girls think they're
hotter than they are yes
why
i think it comes from
a group mentality where like within
their group they may
tell themselves things that are not true
but to comfort their feelings
so then they get the sense of
entitlement that they
deserve this and they
deserve that um
but it's it's females in general it's
not it's not a
it's not a it's not something that i'd
say oh like this is
a bad i think it is a bad thing to be
honest actually um
yeah
and now let's hear from the girls do you
think most girls are objective or do you
think they think they're hotter than
they are
or do they underrate themselves go
around personally i think it depends on
the person because growing up i'm
obviously not skinny hi everyone i'm not
skinny so growing up i was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted by
people blah blah blah blah and i was
just the other one you know so like i
never really thought of myself as
an attractive person like i would never
call myself anything more than a thought
but
now like i don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like i've
grown into myself and i've i've i'm
comfortable with who i am now that like
even if you guys call me delusion or
whatever i think i'm
maybe not a ten let's not go that far
but
like definitely an eight
so like
whether you guys think i am or not
yeah that's got nothing to do with her
but like what is it that took you from a
four to an eight if nothing's changed
what is it that takes loving myself and
and looking in the mirror and not being
disgusted at what i see i understand
that yeah so
but that doesn't you're you're not
necessarily being objective about how
other people view you right because
isn't that what a rating really is like
what you think the vast majority like
like if i rated myself one to ten i give
myself a five i think i'm normal looking
and i just think it's based on my
results i think if i was an eight nine
or ten i would have had modeling
contracts because people in the top
twenty percent of beauty they get they
get modeling contracts what is beauty so
what what is beauty i mean there's a lot
of things like if you
i mean you can you can go online and
have people rate your pictures and they
they rank you one to ten that's wild and
and so you can get you can get a lot of
data that says how attractive you are in
society and men will wait you women will
rate you like every day
how we look is like how we represent
ourselves it's not fun but it's just
like being honest
so
um and it's also like you can take get
dating apps to like you know everyone's
tinder bumble like they have a ranking
for you behind the scenes
yeah damn yeah well
so
um
i don't understand when girls say like
i'm an eight because or sometimes i hear
girls say time because i hear this a lot
where they say like because i love
myself and i'm like confident now but
don't you think attractiveness is based
on results
they may be but i don't care about those
results
to be honest
but do you think then you're not being
objective
about your how attractive you are or how
attractive anyone else might be
um
i guess not but
i think yeah
that stuff's not really important to me
i think when when someone
when someone rates
somebody
why sh why does that have anything to do
with them
like if you rape me if someone rated
like somebody a three and it's just like
okay that's that's your opinion like
it's not like a rating is not a fact
it's an opinion
what do you know i mean everyone's
opinion then well
yeah add up to a consensus maybe not a
fact yeah
consensus yeah
yeah but i think
like i i have a group of friends right
and when i walk into the room with a
group of friends i know immediately
who's gonna get the most attention from
the guys
it's it's not me right i have like a
friend who's like very very attractive
and i know when i walk into a room with
her like the guys talk to her first
because like girls you can kind of just
feel it but i almost wonder when i hear
like and i hear this from girls a lot
like i'm a 10 i'm a 10 i'm a tent
if that's not like rooted in reality
because attractiveness like there's
numbers behind it whether it's just your
results in the world or your dating app
data or
the like the type of guys you can get
yeah this is hmm is a tough time it's
not fun like like i don't enjoy like
walking into a room and knowing
everyone's going to talk to my friend
and not me that's not fun
but i think i'd be delusional if i
thought if i walked into a room and i
thought
wow like they're all going to talk to me
first
i think in addition to your point men
understand hierarchy i was just gonna
say that so we understand that
i'm a four because there are guys that
are five and get this attention guys
that are six they get that attention
seven and so on and so forth whereas
women um
i don't wanna say they live in a
delusion sometimes but it's a case of
well i
because i believe i'm this i am that and
i was going to speak about gender but i
thought let me not because there's
there's a whole
separate topic where
people will go oh
what is gender
and then yeah yeah yeah let's not go
into that place you're gonna get me in
trouble
but i think i do think that women also
understand the hierarchy it's just like
in this day and age
because we've been exposed to what men
want
we kind of understand like oh okay
that's not what men want but i don't
care i'm not i'm never going to be that
you know
without
money
what do you guys think men want
kim kardashian body well let's ask y'all
i want to hear because you said like you
think that girls understand what men
want so i want to go like one by one
do you think what do you think men want
no one at a time sorry
i i couldn't tell you because
i feel like
again i've never been in a relationship
but i've chatted to quite a few guys and
it seems like it's not even that i don't
live up to their standards i feel like
i'm never what they want and i'm like is
it looks okay apparently i checked that
box but they still don't want me there's
a personality yeah you're cool your
vibes but i don't want to wife you like
i don't i don't get it you say you want
personality but you still go and try and
treat a girl like a hoe and i know this
is not all guys i understand that maybe
this is just the guys i attract i don't
know what i'm doing but
okay cool
but i just feel like
maybe
society as a whole not everyone
we do care a lot about looks and i think
that is a lot about
like the first it's just it's very
superficial i think a lot of guys are
very superficial again not all guys but
maybe a certain kind of guys
they just care more about looks could i
give you some advice in regards to like
dealing with a guy that you're not sure
where you stand with him where he's
saying like he might have sex with you
but he's not willing to commit to you or
he might you know take you out on dates
or you might cook dinner for him or you
you might take him on dates you know
whatever it is yeah but there's no
commitment there's no
long-standing chance of a relationship
yeah
if you're dealing with that kind of
situation i say i think there's one
sentence that would clear up the whole
thing would you like to meet my dad
bank what if you don't have any okay
fair enough but would you like to meet
my family would you like to meet with my
brother would you like to meet my mum
as soon as you take it there i'm sorry
but there's an immediate decision that
that partner has to make i'm actually
serious about this
do i want to am i i invested in this
person enough to actually engage with
their family yeah so and honestly
from the beginning if you introduce your
boyfriend your fling whatever it is if
you're trying to get commitment from
them if you introduce them to your
family from the beginning
yeah you can see how they engage with
your family members yeah are they
respectful especially a male counterpart
in the family absolutely because they
can tell
what that guy is up to but what if you
don't have a meal come on
that's i think
i understand that there are other
circumstances obviously i would still
say introduce them to your family do you
have a trusted elder brother type figure
or a father type figure that you trust
if you don't
you know many moms out there have played
the role of both father and mother right
even your friend who's the guy sorry
even your friend who is a guy
about that one yeah yeah i don't know
about that one no no no no because yeah
your friend who's a guy might be
actually that's your boy
[Music]
because he wants you yeah yeah yeah
exactly so he may not be very objective
about it
a family member will be so
um what do you guys think that men want
i kind of agree with otherwise ties like
it's kind of weird um
some guys might just actually just want
looks or body
um some guys want to see like where the
girls going in the career or what she's
actually interested in some guys i don't
know
um
okay they might have some
similarities or certain i did i don't
know i don't actually know what about
you
um
from what i've gathered from from guys
that have been interested in me
um as well as like guy friends
um
most of the time they don't want a
plus-sized girl because
either they're afraid
or embarrassed or they're afraid
whatever
um
or if they do they only want to be
low-key about it they don't want to show
you off they don't want people to know
that they're that they're
like talking to you or trying to do a
thing with you
but
most of the the guy friends
that i've had usually want
like
girls definitely big bum it's always a
big bum
always always always
and then but the thing is most of the
time they want the the big bum but they
don't want the the things that come with
the big bum like the natural stuff that
comes with the other outer glass yeah
they want the the nice boom like figure
so i want to hear from the guys
um what what do you guys what do you all
want if you guys wanted to get married
what would you look for in a wife
do you want to go home
i'm going to get hate for this but
submissiveness
oh that's
may not be religious but i try to be
submission isn't the word that i
tend to use
you're like if a woman is submissive to
god
then she will do her duty as a wife
yeah what i require from a wife is fun
if there's one word is cooperativeness
what does that mean that you have a wife
a partner that is going to ride or die
with you towards the same goal towards
the same end yeah
that is the fundamental quality that i
require from a woman
beauty will fade
facts beauty will fade not undertale not
all the time look there are some
50-year-old women out there that still
got a god bless them yeah yeah right
right
but listen cooperativeness
like are you going to be holding it down
you know whilst i'm struggling at work
or
you know if there's kids at home crying
and screaming are you gonna give up easy
what kind of character do you have do
you have resilience do you have like the
ability to give me peace when i need it
are you gonna be able to take care of
things
as i need you to when i need you to yeah
like
i'm not saying have a woman like at the
end of a whip yo do this for me do that
for me no no no
is that
[Laughter]
the main thing i think is just that
fundamental cooperativeness that we
agree towards the same similar goal or
the same goal and that we're both
gunning for that together now we might
have separate roles
when gunning for that same goal yeah but
the goal is the same and if she's on
board that's it yeah i agree what about
you um
you said a lot of things as well so but
like just to add on to what you guys
said i i just want peace i want someone
that can bring me peace when i come back
from the world
um that i'm having to fight in order to
kind of bring
something
to the table um
from your answers ladies it sounded like
you girls didn't really know what men
want
i didn't say anything
fair enough fair enough well so like
that would more indicate you don't know
what men want and when i ask you the
question you say nothing no thank you
don't be fair they they answered so and
then it continued
hey all right but yeah it
it sounds like you have an indication of
what you think men want and you're doing
the things that you think
men want and then you're not getting the
results exact of what you want
i think can i can i answer your question
um
i somewhat agree i
personally it's very debatable because
sometimes sometimes women don't know
what they want and like you said like we
think sometimes we think we know what
they want by
like doing stuff like cooking and
cleaning and like spending more time
with them but like
it's like when a guy approaches them
first obviously
they think that they can look in and
like oh let me try to be fair like oh
let me try this let me try that and it's
like
at the end we might not get what they
want and then we'll obviously get angry
because they are they approached us
first and it's just like what did you
well what did you want in the beginning
without any sex yeah of course
so it's just but like in this like
especially like i'm 24 as well like i'm
like if you like if you approach me and
like you really want no like you should
know what you like guys you should know
what you want as well like even sex yeah
yeah
yeah like
and then when when
when we don't want that
you look mad
do they get mad or do they move on no
some of them get mad
all right so what they're both yeah both
yeah fair enough uh so what i'd find
what i'd say is
male and female relationships are
transactional men want sex women want
relationships
women control access to sex
men control access to relationships
that's true it's a game that you're
playing with a guy
if you can withhold sex long enough for
him to kind of get to the point where he
feels like he needs to wife you
then you you're playing the game right
and
but and also a lot of guys
if they know you've slept with guys
before like very quickly they're they're
and they want to date you but you're
making them wait they're just thinking
like what what am i doing here you
didn't make him wait
and so a lot of guys get frustrated and
just leave because you know it's like
you slept with three guys on the
football team so why on earth am i
waiting for this
i think i should do the same but then
that just shows you wasn't serious in
the first place then that just shows
that he was just actually there for sex
because
no no tom got it quicker than
no it shows one men value purity so they
don't want a girl that slept with a lot
of guys that is fun for them but it's
fine for them to do
yeah because men and women are different
mm-hmm like it's easy for us you can
walk outside i could walk outside
what no i i agree we're all human like
it's not like girls don't want to have
sex
but it's
valuable to a guy to have a girl that
hasn't had as many experiences because
it lowers your value the more people you
slept with i find that right
biologically men and women are different
so historically men had to ensure
paternity so they had to make sure that
the woman that they were sleeping with
like that she was passing on his genes
and so we can't make our biological like
need go away the same way we can't help
that we like men taller than us because
historically we had to find a guy to
protect us it's just innate in them they
can't help it
it like
how is ish how would you feel if you
were dating a girl and you found out
later like after you were together that
she slept with three of your boys oh my
but that's the best boys okay no let's
say let's say three three acquaintances
you don't know them well
that's still the same i found out later
yeah yeah no i'd be human yeah yeah
yeah if i if i knew before
then i would have
i would have made a choice obviously i
wouldn't do it but i would have made a
choice to be there but if if i know
later on now i'm in deep then i would be
fuming because i've invested all this
time effort money to know that there's
brothers
in and around me looking at me going
yeah no i've now it kind of makes you
look yeah now what if what if you waited
a month to bang her and you found out
that all of them slept with her out on
the first date
yeah i'm fighting everyone
because a guy wants you to like view him
as the best that like you can do
so if if we're going around making one
guy wait and make giving it to another
guy immediately like to the guy
it's like you don't like him you liked
the other guys more and you're just
settling for the other guy right would
you man was that yeah oh yeah yeah
that's a good point because um men don't
like to feel like they're being settled
for at all i think i think them like um
feeling like a woman is there to settle
for him
uh men like you said does like to feel
like um he is the best little
that woman wants kind of thing
um
[Music]
so the thing is i think
you know
whoever you
get as a partner
they want to be treated like a 10 and
you want to be treated like a 10.
whether you are objectively in terms of
beauty standards or not isn't the point
the kind of relationship you have with
your partner you should be
each other's 10.
do you get what i'm saying but
is that is that possible if uh
like a five is going for a 10
i don't think so i don't know
yeah that's the the problem is i don't
think that can happen where everyone
gets their first choice because
especially nowadays you have eighty
percent of women sleeping with twenty
percent of guys
so
the five thinks she's an eight because
she's sleeping with the eight nine or
ten and so
when she gets married she's gonna view
her husband as less that's another issue
with um sleeping with a lot of guys did
you know if you sleep with more than
five guys your chance of a happy
marriage after 10 years it goes from 80
to 25 percent
why why casual sex why because because
the more men you sleep with it you lose
your ability to bond with each one
yeah it's pair bonding so so if you
sleep with one guy you're going to
compare the next guy to him if you sleep
with 10 guys you compare all 10 if you
sleep with 20 you compare all 20. and
guys hate being compared to other guys
well they hate being but it makes you
more divorced like yeah you're not
likely to be divorced but you're more
likely to leave if you did that because
you're with your husband thinking about
the last like 10 guys that maybe weren't
as good
as the one you married
god damn
[Laughter]
are you okay
yeah that's just mad i think that's my
because like like made you thinking it
yeah cause wait but mostly girls okay
girls always go for like a relationship
so cool if they sleep with
more than 10 people
and then they find okay more than five
people and they find someone
are they still gonna be
okay call like he's not as best as jake
like
well
i think
it depends on the girl
it absolutely depends on the girl okay
but and it depends who she marries does
she marry a guy that's better than all
the guys she slept with or does she feel
like she's settled
like like i'll give you an example if
there's a guy like for me and i didn't
realize what i was doing right but if
there's a guy that to me is like like a
nine right and he's talking to me i'm
like why are you talking to me because i
i just immediately think that he wants
like yeah yeah because i'm like you're a
little out of my life
yeah
and it's because and i didn't realize
that's an innate like response to not
wanting to be alpha widowed and alpha
widow is basically when you sleep with a
guy that's so high value no one else can
compare
and and so every guy so your husband
might pay for it because
you're sleeping with your husband
wishing it was the other guy
and i don't know about you but i've i've
found that there's always girls always
have one x that they like can't get up
can't get over that they can't it
doesn't matter who they date after
they're always thinking about that last
x and when i was in college i remember
just thinking wow this is so weird like
everyone's got that one
and that's everyone's alpha widow
like i'll give you a story i tell this
story all the time on my show so
there was a girl i went to school with
she was like the girl next door you
never would have known she um
she
slept with a guy or she was dating a guy
for like a month freshman year okay and
they broke up because he was kind of a
player like he cheated on her like in
like a month like that's so soon yeah i
know i know
i'm like you couldn't make it a month
anyways have
so like fast forward four years later
she's dating a new guy this man treats
her like a queen okay he bought her a
house
he bought her yeah she bought her a
house moves her into the house
they're still together them on amazon
yeah
no they're still together the two this
day i would say he probably wasn't as
like good looking as the guy from
freshman year had like as much of a
smooth talker but like like good
reliable responsible guy bought her a
house moved her in all this stuff we're
at a party okay
and uh
yeah i'm at a party and she's there and
her the guy that bought her the house
isn't coming but he's gonna get there in
like an hour okay
and i see her she goes into the bathroom
and i'm like why is that like where that
where'd um where'd she go and
and um
and and um
she she comes i see her come out of the
bathroom
with um the guy from freshman
psychology she was sleeping with him in
the back i don't know how long or what
happened i just i just was like and you
never would have known because she was
like the girl next door and um yeah
she's like still with that the other guy
today
and that's so when i think of alpha
widow that's what i think of was she
drunk
i don't know probably
yeah no an excuse no
i don't like i wasn't super close with
her like that we were just on the like
we just like we're the same friends
right but i i was like oh my god this
happened so long and this is for like
she's probably hooking up with him the
whole time and so when i think of an
alpha like that's that's the problem
when you get a bigger and bigger body
count is like you're more likely to find
a guy that the next guy can't compete
with especially if you're batting out of
your league
wow
a house are you stupid
with the other guy that's tough
he was did he find out how many i
started thinking i don't know i don't i
don't like it it wasn't yo this was i
was a senior so i was just about to like
leave the school so i was just like
that's not i'm graduating i'm not gonna
like
i'm sorry but men really shouldn't lead
with their wallets when it comes to you
know
engaging with females they should not
they really should not and they should
yes money is a bonus
yeah it's a nice thing to have it's a
nice thing to flaunt and it's a nice
thing to spend on your on your your
partner yeah
but if you're gonna buy a house
and then just like he didn't
lead with his wallet it was after a
couple years
yeah they were they were together for
like a minute like if he's getting
cheated on but he didn't know i'm
telling you like some guys and i i maybe
you guys would disagree but i don't
think the boyfriends i think it's very
hard for men to tell
if you're the girl's second choice
because she might you might not be
fighting all the time you might you you
really probably won't ever know
the friends know
yeah yeah yeah
and they won't tell you either the
family member
are you gonna tell the girlfriend if
your friend's cheating yes
i personally
she's let's say she has a boyfriend yeah
yeah she's cheating oh
i think both genders are loyal to each
other in that way exactly but we're not
gonna we're not gonna snitch if our
girl's cheating or if the guy's cheating
that's the thing so look i've been
friends with lj's since we were like 14
years i was 14 years old he's 16. right
like we've been friends for over 10
years right if i if i knew that he had a
wife and he was cheating on her
he i think i could look him in the eye
and say we would probably fight
i think i could look him in the eye and
just genuinely that wasn't the question
would you i mean
something to say well yeah you might say
it to him but you're not going to go to
his wife well i would probably give him
an ultimatum and say if you aren't going
to tell your wife right but you're
something's going to happen
you're not the rule control perhaps
perhaps that's the case he's capping no
no i don't think i'm gonna hear me out
hear me out i think you're capping on
the sense that if you were in the
situation yes i believe you'd get angry
with me i am more loyal to my principles
than i am my friend
i think you'd get at him i think as a
man of principle you would speak to him
you'd fight him you'd have that
discussion with him yeah i don't think
you would go to the world
personally i don't think it's i don't
think it's right
okay i i agree
it's not right for me to directly speak
to her let me out here sorry go go a
bond is between two people they're in a
relationship together there is no third
person yeah the moment you're going to
interfere in that right
you're playing a dangerous game yeah i
agree it's a dangerous game you don't
know that she she may already know that
he's cheating yeah but she's happy with
the benefits the moment you come no hit
me up the moment of it's touching him
so women married or are in relationships
mainly for status yeah i get that i get
that let me finish
they understand
that if they are with a man of high
value they are willing to compromise the
idea of cheating because they understand
that they may not be able to get another
man of that kind of value or status so
they are willing to go through the
[ __ ] as long as it's not
out in the open and people don't know
and yeah
and and
girls are more attracted to guys that
cheat i mean why do you think they say
men are trash why do you think they're
always complaining about getting cheated
on we pick them
like
because historically there's biological
roots to everything so historically if a
man could take care of other women that
that meant that um like that meant that
he could take care of us so if we see
that he's taking care of another woman
like then we're attracted to that
it's kind of messed up but how many
girls do you know that get cheated on
and go back
only
that's probably some sorry some some
women
um sometimes go back because that's
probably the only guy she knows like do
you know what i mean some sometimes
women don't want to explore another like
everything with another man she doesn't
think she can do better mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's true yeah
interesting
because it reminds me of like the whole
guma thing in italian mafias where a
mafia boss will always have a gumma a
second wife or another woman and it
makes sense because he's of such high
status these women can't get anyone else
he's literally the top of the food chain
but it's not surely it's not morally
acceptable for a man to have
sexual relations outside of marriage
because there's no commitment there so
the woman that is the other woman
she there's no security for that person
is there well yeah but some girls like
to be side checks well here's the thing
this is that real
religion what go ahead i was going to
say this is why i think i think polygyny
is the word where a man marries multiple
women
is that polygamy okay
where a man marries multiple women at
least that that there is that marriage
contract to provide that woman with a
certain set of rights a certain kind of
type of security there whereas if you're
just in a monogamous a monogamous you
know marriage where you're stepping out
of that
then it's not
true you're not being transparent it's
not fair on the oh no all right talking
about morality i'm just talking about
what is sure so i mean i'm not saying oh
it's good to cheat on your wife but i'm
saying that girls it happens when girls
like guys that cheating can get multiple
girls they we do i mean i'm not yeah i'm
not saying like like i i personally like
wouldn't i wouldn't want to be involved
but there's a part of like our biology
that just says if he
can get other women that's attractive to
us yeah and plus i don't really put it
on like if a girl wants to be a side
chick that is her own damn fault yeah
like you picked that life
i'm not i'm not gonna say oh like you're
putting her in a bad position because
you're not taking care of her i'm saying
you put your she put herself in a bad
position
you picked it
oh
super chat oh super chats okay
um okay guys so i'm gonna do some super
chats real quick
let me scroll okay
um
let's see we got a flaming dragon with
the emoji alex baxter nothing to comment
hope this helps with the studio thanks
for the content you're really helping
men and women out there thank you so
much alex 100 super chat
um guys right now we're saving to get
another camera we're saving to get
another camera angle so all these super
chats really help go towards the studio
we're getting new lights tomorrow so
that's going to be improved um
but to
yeah we want one more camera okay sam
acts please do a call-in section it will
be so much cheaper for me the reason
women's be sleeping around is because
there is is so bad is due to pair
bonding um if you guys send me super
chats i will buy the equipment and we
will do a call-in show
sam acts men only require three things
from a woman and sex is the single most
important thing to a man you you saying
no when we only want one of three things
makes you makes you useless to us men
want
info vader men want fit feminine and
friendly kevin samuels nailed it the
worst things are attitude and masculine
energy men don't want to date another
man dragon stallion sounds like the
ladies are getting dating attention and
not marriage attention and marriage
attention can be used sentience
ladies it's very simple men want
hoes for a fun time and a chaste
virtuous woman for a wife and the mother
of his legacy the only time men want a
long term 304 as if his if if she is his
if she is his alone and he wants
the one who made her
and he was oh and he was the one who
made her one um passive rebellion low
body count
feminine agreeable and beauty is 80
percent of what men want from a woman
sam acts women need to better understand
that there's a difference between sexual
attraction and relationship attention
when a woman figures out that she can
start she can start selecting a mate
passionate rebellion if a man does not
want to wife you it is because he
doesn't find you attractive enough to
give you that much much time and
resources
and susie the dating world is like a
free market and free markets define
things like rank and value it's not the
end of the world you just have to
compete gus men are the consumers of the
female beauty female beauty men decide
bowsey tegan says er
tegan says she's an eight um mgtow by
logic
women do know the truth about their
level of attractiveness they just lie
for the gains like everything else
bowsey um why buy the cow when you get
the milk for free ryan five
the emoji
duntians
women are quick to point out a man what
a man should do or what makes a real man
can three women articulate what a modern
woman's role is for a traditional man
who has his money his purpose and his
and he has already met these standards
sam acts part three the modern women
believes their standards make them worth
it but refuse to understand that their
standards have turned them into a zex
toy to be played with and discarded
strange place or i could just go
overseas and look for and get the woman
or i could just go overseas the women
look and act better there anyways
argument solves have a good one we
actually are overseas we're in england
[Laughter]
matt butcher so i prefer women who weigh
less than me gus if women dated up
throughout history doesn't that mean
that men are the ones who actually
settle that's a good point
sam acts
part one part of the problem is that
women think they are tens when they're
actually closer to threes and fours
men's dictate men dictate a woman's
dating value not women part three coming
up um bowsey them saying they don't care
about money is cap sam acts part of the
problem is that women think there are
tens when they're actually closer to
three and four is men dictate a woman's
value not women part two coming up um
matt butcher off topic but please do a
show on the macro
on the macro on relationships and
marriage for a man all this time effort
and money you find out a year later
later she is not what she presented
herself to be informator um for a woman
to settle she needs to know what she can
keep most modern women will choose men
out of their league and then get smashed
and dash but she thinks she can keep a
man like that wrong um are there any
others that they just sent or no
because otherwise i'll just refresh it
hold on just to make sure
um
oh okay yeah there's three more so
um there's 80 percent of the guys
screaming at women who refuse to see
them because they're too busy gazing
upwards at the guys who cr constantly
treat them like crap um zen teens modern
women fail to realize and understands
the pair understand the paradox of
choice that they have as their body
counts increase they will always have
fomo by comparing men to his
predecessors especially after body
number five cable jones you are
beautiful
okay
or maybe maybe them i don't know like it
could be anyone
um
damn wow
you have quite an articulate group of
fans after this
concerned yeah so so next question
um
if
what
if women are allowed to have height
filters
why
um on dating apps why can't men have
weight filters he says they call them
you said they can't they don't
oh i don't see a post i don't see them i
know you don't see a problem you don't
see a problem no i don't see a problem
okay
i also don't see a problem what you like
what you like yeah you like what you
like yeah yeah what was your preference
whether you're brave enough to present
what you like to actually like yes
what do you mean brave enough to present
people are just scared to
be themse yeah to say oh i like a bigger
girl or
i like like slim like really slim
because more times like what tegan's
saying people actually just go for
not all the time let me correct myself
but majority of the time people actually
go for people that are slim or
hourglass big booty kim k type body
so
i don't i just think his preference yeah
well that's probably the most in demand
is the hourglass body yeah like that's
probably just what they like the most
like
you know i think girls like what six
four guys the most
six four six four five
two six
six two i think on dating apps that six
four is like the primary my neck is
gonna be doing up elastic girl
yeah it's kind of it's kind of weird
because some girls are like
five foot with a six foot four mm-hmm
yeah
how does that correlate how does that
look for guy
how i'm five foots one so i don't know
it just depends
so the one question i have is
do you guys think
women will say that we want a guy and
not you guys particular but i hear this
often from women six foot six six inches
six figures have you heard that before
yes yes yes yes and i don't agree yeah
so
but at the same time at the same time
they shame men for what they want so
they'll call them fat phobic or the new
one is aegis
what does that mean
ages so so they say that they say that
men discriminate against overweight
women and old women
but when a woman has a standard we don't
go up to the women and say oh you're
discriminating against broke men and
short men
i would but i don't think i represent
all women so you would do what i would
tell them that's not that's not fair i
think there's such a double standard in
society when it comes oh
absolutely television
you'll say it's not fair to date a broke
man like like that you shouldn't
disagree yeah oh i think you should
why would you want to date a guy that's
going nowhere in life not broke
like if a guy if a guy can't hold a job
i think they're trying to be very nice
to be fair as well i do think i am
actually too nice okay i have been
something i might need to work on i've
been [ __ ] over for being too nice okay
i know that's something don't make that
mistake again because honestly i would
not tell you as a man yeah if your
preference is say someone that's tall go
for a tall guy if your preference is
someone that is has six figures and you
can get that go get that
but if like
if you're gonna try and convince me that
money occupation status in life in a man
is not something that you're concerned
with
just come on don't lie now do you know
what i'm saying
i'll be honest with you money is not a
big thing for me
i understand if you're not materialistic
23. yes that's typical women
no women it tends to switch where money
becomes more important around like 26.
and that makes sense as well because men
don't really peak until they're like in
their 30s yeah yeah money you might not
care now but when you're picking a guy
that you may have kids with and you'd
have to rely on him for a couple years
while you raise the kids
um it becomes more important
fair enough fun i mean obviously i'm
young in it but at my age i don't even
see kids in my future so i think that's
also why
i prioritize money less yeah i wouldn't
do you think that is might change with
age as well potentially
i feel like
so there was this guy i was talking to
he
was unemployed
and
he was just selling drugs to get by
yeah
so bro what are you doing i know we're
not talking anymore it didn't last very
long we are too pretty to be deal no i'm
serious you can get a guy with a job
like
you're very pretty
you know what it is are you successful
give people benefit of the doubt and
that is i understand yeah
oh come on girl you had to have had guys
with real jobs interested i don't
believe like i do not believe for a
second you are 23 you're in shape you're
attractive you're you're nice to be
around you're telling me a drug dealer
that was why why would you pick him
i didn't
pick him
i met him and i was like see a smooth
talk he had ambition i was like i'm not
gonna knock anyone because i'm
unemployed right now i don't have a job
i'm basically broke i'm living at home
so he's more ambitious than you
he's making that money for the drug deal
but i don't know his ambition
i don't get it
did he at least have good customer
service he's a good drug dealer i mean i
don't i didn't get anything off him he
wasn't my drug dealer i don't do drugs
i was like do you know what i'll give
him the benefit of the doubt and i was
like at least he's not living at home
not trying to get a job he was trying to
get a job he was a plan he could have
been lying to me but i believed him when
he said he was trying to get a job so i
was like i'm not gonna say no just
because
i wouldn't automatically label you a
slacker just because you're a drug
dealer
is this a guy that put you in the friend
zone
no okay does he want to date you
i don't chat to him anymore oh okay did
you end it with him yeah
i'm glad
[Laughter]
but yeah i mean i'm probably not the
best person to ask because i am quite
inexperienced but just at least from my
point of view now at my age
money is not a big thing for me and i
think maybe with my career as well
personally i find it's quite hard to
make money through dance i'm not doing
it for the money i'm doing it because i
enjoy it i don't want to work nine to
five in an office that's just not me i
like to do something creative
and i feel like dance is underfunded
people don't really want to pay dancers
they want us to work for free
we just do it for the exposure so
um
yeah so for me yeah money is not the
motive
would i like a guy that had money yeah
but it's not the main for me
but if if there's two guys in front of
you
and one was making six figures and one
wasn't you'd pick the guy that makes six
figures am i right or wrong it depends
on what the other guy's doing if the
other guy's doing something creative
i'll go for him he'd rather go for the
creative guy that makes less money yes
okay i feel like in all of the
conversations that we've had we haven't
actually spoken about feelings
because feelings are a big part of
relationships yeah right
no okay not important no i don't think i
don't think your feelings are important
if when selecting a long-term partner
it doesn't it doesn't know because
feelings come and go
suddenly that's that's why i think a lot
of modern women are selfish because
they'll leave a marriage because of
their feelings your feelings are they're
expected to come and go
so like when when i'm looking for
someone like long-term
you want someone that has character
and
i mean you're attracted to but do i
think like by feelings are that
important and picking up someone to
marry and like build a family with well
yeah because one thing
what do you get the next day you love
him
it's like feelings come and go they're
like the ocean the week before my period
i'll probably hate him
but there's still those feelings there
for that person they don't just shut off
sometimes in marriage for if you're
gonna marry a guy so so i'm 25. let's
say i get married at 30 okay and let's
say i live to be 80. that's that's 50
years
so i think at some point i probably
won't like him that much but it's about
like duty and commitment
but like a lot of modern women it's
about it's about
like how we feel in the moment instead
of like
what
is the best choice for us long term and
we can even see this with you i mean
a drug deal i mean come on
nothing that was a mistake okay i've
dated guys i should have dated like i'm
not i'm not saying i'm perfect but i
think as women like
historically a lot of times men made
decisions for us when it comes to dating
and i think there's a reason for that
because a lot of times we pick wrong
because we rely on our feelings well can
i add to that because it's it's
interesting to me uh
coming from a muslim background
dating is just
it's considered forbidden in in islam
the reason for that being is that
let's say if i'm dating a woman i'm not
giving her any commitment i could just
take advantage of her sexually and then
move on
right there's no kind of commitment
there she might get heartbroken
emotionally troubled all sorts of things
um but
in islam what you're supposed to do is
just courtship i think you're supposed
to get to know
whoever
but families are involved from the
get-go you're supposed to vet the
partner that you're with do you know
what i mean you can't just go in there
blind thinking okay i'm going to just
figure this out day to day go speak to
their family members let them speak to
yours engage in that way so that you can
really understand what this kind what
this person that you want to be your
partner is all about
if you're gonna go in there dating oh
yeah you know let's have some fun let's
go to the theater let's go do this let's
go do that
that's fine but
it doesn't
uh reveal to you whether you guys would
be good partners long term whether you
guys would be able to take care of
children whether in the stressful days
you guys are gonna not tear each other's
heads off and all this kind of stuff
because that's when it's all rosy the
first couple of years of dating but
dating i think is just it's an illusion
you either are gunning towards
commitment
or you're just playing pretend you're in
a in a situation with someone and it's
not really truthfully going to go
anywhere
if you aren't discussing commitment from
the get-go in my opinion anyway
like what's what's the point what is the
point of dating if there's not
commitment down the line in the future
it doesn't make sense to me like dating
in general just dating aimlessly as well
what do you guys think about that
i would agree yeah i get that but but i
also feel like that is but sometimes
i'll deal with you
and i feel like it's not an ideal world
and i feel like well for me personally i
would
in an ideal world i would like to be
friends with someone for a long time so
i can get to know them what they're like
on a friendship level obviously not the
same as being in a relationship then i
get to know what they're liking hard
situations good situations and then if
there's a vibe
it moves on or for me i would rather if
it was a date and situation i would get
to know them over a long period of time
hold back on sex hold back on certain
things but i just feel like for me so
many guys don't want to wait yeah so
it's just really hard
it's really hard or they want they want
sex to then give you the commitment that
you want basically
yeah that's backwards i don't agree with
you that's what i'm saying
i agree like
it's but a lot of times i don't think
girls have the conversations up front i
mean it depends what you want do you
like if you want a boyfriend if you want
to be married but i think a lot of times
having the conversation up front about
like where this is going
is is helpful
and also involving like like i don't
know um i know some of you said that you
don't have fathers to help you with this
but i always involve my dad i like tell
them about the guys i'm dating and it's
really helpful because men can kind of
see through like other guys [ __ ] a
lot faster than you
so if i'm if i'm like seeing a guy or
i'm going on dates with him and i like
tell my dad like stuff he's saying or
whatever like my dad will tell me yes or
no and i try to listen to him
and he's always right what were you
going to say you said about feelings you
said it's not an ideal
go ahead
well i just
i don't even know where i'm going with
this but
in a in a long-term relationship as much
as like you have duties and you have
like
them hard situations obviously
but
there needs to be some sort of
connection to want to stay with that
person
sure for that amount of time
for that amount of time don't you think
of course
oh yeah i mean you have to get along in
order to get to the point yeah
but you guys are saying how feeling
comes and goes like are you not gonna i
think they may have that feeling i think
i think guys i think i think they mean
like so in like in the certain
situations like you're married obviously
and like i don't know like if
something's if something is happening
not in their relationship but if
something is just happening in general
sometimes you just gotta put your
feelings in the side and deal with that
situation i think that's what they i
think that's no
what i understand by
feeling should not be the judgment of
how you pick your relationships is the
fact that if you feel something towards
someone at a mo that moment right that
person could be for example broke a drug
dealer doing whatever he wants to be
doing right and you're going oh my gosh
i love him i feel my feelings are
telling me i want to be with him you
will make a bad decision that will have
long-term consequences which is why we
say feelings should not be the biggest
or the most relevant point of why you
are in a relationship they shouldn't
dictate a relationship it should be
um
things like status it should be job it
should be character right all of these
things are the focus of what will be
good for or conducive for a long-term
relationship if you're picking based on
feelings lord knows lord knows you're
not going to have a great time
but feeling
like you have to take that into account
in
the the in a small capacity yes yeah
that's what i would i would say it's
secondary
like i would say characters above all
else
but in high i'm sorry shortcuts
don't worry
you're in a long-term relationship and
you went for this person because of his
status because of whatever whatever but
you're in the worst relationship and
you're married to this person obviously
you don't have to stay but you've chosen
this person because of
what they do yeah what they do then
you'll have kids which you'll find your
joy through
well if you don't want to yeah okay so
those are
other obstacles that you you may face
like if you don't want kids then that's
something that's your own choice like
there will be
in the long term you'll find that there
will be so many things that you would
have avoided
because you chose
based on the factors that were important
as opposed to using your feelings you'll
find that
a lot of relationships that you may have
been in previously may have not
been great or may have not gone well due
to you picking
based on your feelings yeah if and i can
i can even say firsthand like i've
picked guys that i like i shouldn't have
picked
because like you know of of my feelings
but i've just learned that like
character is the most important thing
especially when choosing a husband
but when feelings aren't involved isn't
that when you start going looking to
other places to find out define that
feeling well i think that's a choice i
mean i think some women with low
character that's what they do not just
women
no you're right men too i just see it
more with women because women initiate
80 of divorces
so so women leave much more that if
you're college educated it's 90 percent
yeah so i mean your chance of getting
divorced is quite low and i think that's
because women are more based in feelings
and men are more based in logic because
we're chemically different every single
day based on where we are in our cycle
could i add to that quickly um i do find
it interesting for like how
so many women initiate divorce
whereas
i can't say this is the case for all
abrahamic religions
but in judaism
for example if a man and a woman are
going to get a divorce a woman literally
has to seek permission from their
husbands to get divorced
i'm not saying that that's a good thing
or a bad thing or whatever i'm not here
to judge judaism and their rulings but
it's interesting to me that when we look
at like ancient scripture
it's essentially saying that
a woman when making that choice might be
making that choice
out of their feelings and not being
perhaps objective about the marriage
itself
but obviously women should have
the opportunity to divorce but why is it
that we're seeing such a high divorce
rate and why is it that women are
initiating it more than men are
there's no consequence
yeah
because i mean you can get divorced and
get
child support for 18 years
so do you think divorce is therefore
incentivized
yes oh my gosh yeah and and social media
i think specifically for women i think
girls think that on the other side it's
it's a lot happier than it is because
you see a lot of women like coping on
social media and it's really sad like
i'll always see women talk about oh i'm
so happy to be in my 30s and single and
alone and i'm just like yeah okay
even though statistically study after
study after study will say that if you
make it to 45 and you're still alone and
single like that is the least happy
group wow
but
i mean that's just kind of how women
cope and so it's almost like marketing
the single life to the married women
do you think men would initiate divorce
more if there weren't these grave
consequences
for example child support yeah et cetera
taken off they're taking half
i don't understand why girls get to take
half like you can get a job too like i
don't i don't get it yeah i don't get
divorced it's a bit weird
do you think it's purely because um how
it's been back in the day
women taking half is based on the fact
that they would have the kids as well
yeah
i think that's what it was
and certainly men are the providers
could you say that again women would
have the kids
in
in situation of divorce in back in the
day
when are we talking about no no not that
far back sorry okay okay okay
um probably 20 30 years okay okay okay
yeah yeah yeah
because because before that let's be
honest like women were the property of
their fathers before until they became
the property of their husbands do you
get what i'm saying like women in the
west have only had the right to have
property in i think the 19th century or
maybe the 18th century yeah
funny thing is though like
um if we look back before that
you know we're looking at women being
property like i say
we're looking uh say when islam was
initially originated that was like the
first religious tradition that gave
women the right for property in
situations of divorce a man is supposed
to provide what's called a maha which is
like a security when they get married
so a man is supposed to give that woman
assets in case of a divorce
so that that woman can rely on those
assets
but that doesn't mean she's entitled to
half his
you know stuff
it just means that he has provided that
security in case of a divorce and if she
divorces that's totally her choice and
she can run off with that mahad which is
rightfully hers and in even in a
marriage her money is her money whereas
the man's money is everyone's money it's
the family's money do you get what i'm
saying so it's kind of a different it's
a different thing
but i digress
did you know the top five richest women
in the world made their bags through
divorce
wow
that is so messed up
um so if a girl
wants to have kids right and she doesn't
get the men that she wants like like oh
the men that she wants don't want her do
you think she should settle for a guy
that she doesn't want no absolutely not
no no
look how many people are in the world
you can find
the one you want
somewhere else well i mean i think if
the men you want constantly don't want
you it means something's wrong with you
so there's probably something wrong with
her
either yeah either she's not either
she's not attractive enough to get it or
something's wrong with her character if
you constantly the men that you want
don't want you
no but there's going to be there's going
to be a guy that does want her like this
there's so many people
there are guys there are guys that want
her but not the ones that she wants
oh okay so either she's batting out of
her league
right yeah yeah yeah so i'm saying if if
that
like continues to be the case should she
settle for a guy she doesn't want
if that happens no i still say no
because it's just like
you're not going to be happy if you
don't you're just not going to be happy
and it's just going to be a thing where
okay cool i've settled mm-hmm and you're
still not yes you got your kids cool my
dreams are my kids now but
you're not happy yeah so so second
question how much money do you think you
need to retire
at 65.
yeah london
costs
a lot
sorry could you be more specific about
what you mean there so at 65 if you want
to retire and not work till you die okay
but you own your house or something like
that
yes okay
i'll take two million you need to earn
like a mortgage we're assuming that
you've paid off your mortgage by 65.
yeah okay own your house and in order
for you to live another let's say 30
more years yeah how much money would you
need is this just like bare minimum yeah
minimum oh
two million i'd say
i think
point five three mill was a good show
what about you guys
if it's minimum okay i take about two
yeah two million honestly no idea so yes
he got it's 2.5 million
so
and the average women i don't know what
it is in the uk but i know it's similar
the average woman in the us makes um 35
000 per year in u.s dollars and i know
it's something similar in the uk when
you take the conversion
so
those women that choose not to settle
will end up homeless women are the
largest and like growing homeless
population
wow dumb
so
if they choose not to settle
then i mean their other option and
they're not making close to six figures
the option is die alone and on the
streets
do you think maybe
that the better option would be maybe
get a guy that you're not as attracted
to
i mean it's better than dying at
homeless sure
that's the case
it's no it's no win for her either way
like it's just sad regardless she's like
she's gonna be on the street dining
alone and then she doesn't she's gonna
live with the guy for the rest of her
life that she does that she doesn't want
and she who she doesn't like so there's
no way i don't think i'm sad i think
it's the consequence of a choice she
made because she the reason she's not
satisfied with the guys on her level
she's had she's slept with too many guys
that are out of her level so what if she
hasn't yeah or she focused on her career
when she was younger and then decided to
yeah
but
should women not focus on their career
to to a certain extent whether that they
can provide themselves that level of
security financially in case of divorce
and so on obviously in divorces women
get half of the man's staff
but that financial cushion surely that's
a bit of a blessing for a woman to
remain independent if she so chooses to
i think it's a choice that a woman makes
to decide to focus on her career um as
opposed to find a partner at the age
where you would consider a woman being
in her
beauty prime as such 20 to 24 yeah that
that kind of age range if she doesn't
want to find a man in that age that's
fair she wants to focus on her career do
she's got to do what she does but more
so than anything there are consequences
that when she gets to the
29 30s she's going to find that the guys
that she once wanted
or one could have or could have are no
longer interested in her maybe
change
maybe what what she what she wanted then
as opposed to like once she's lived her
life figured out like who she is where
she wants to go with like maybe what she
wants in a guy might change well it
typically it typically does i mean like
women look for more long-term security
the older they get yeah um but i think
his point is that a woman's peak like
the most like if you survey men between
the age of like 20 and 80 a woman's peak
attractiveness is somewhere around the
age of 22 or 23.
and you're 50 of your options like so on
dating apps if we took your your matches
from when you were 18 to when you were
30 they go down by 50 percent
from from your early 20s to your 30s wow
so the the problem is if a girl is
dating at a young age she's used to
getting the guys let's say she's a seven
okay so she can attract the guys that
are sevens eights nines and tens
because you know they'll typically deal
with a girl that's a seven
so then she goes through 20 she focuses
on her career she hits 30 she says i'm
ready to get married
those guys have no interest in her
because they want the 22 year olds
and then she hits 30 and she she's not
satisfied with the partners that she
gets
so this is all based on like a choice
that she made which is which is fine i
think everyone should have the right to
do what they want to do but i don't know
if we're always honest about the
consequences
yeah i think that's a very good point
very much so
you know any any comments what do you
guys think of that yeah i feel like
i can't say anything about statistics
but i feel like just from my observation
of people i know and just people in
general i find a lot of women finding
solid good relationships in their older
lives around the ages of 50 even 60. and
i like so my mom my parents split up
when i was young she hadn't dated anyone
for ages and then two years ago she's
been with this guy and they've been
proper solid they're like really good
and i've seen that and a lot of my mom's
friends as well they'd they when they
were young didn't work out they divorced
they got kids they don't have kids but
they're finding
love and good solid relationships and
security in their older lives and i feel
like
even the way people view age and society
now is changing and i feel like the
older you are is less stigma it's still
a lot of stigma but just at least for me
people i know
50 years a new 40 40 is the new 30 and
30's and 20 in my view and i feel like
there are so many opportunities to find
love when you're older where they
weren't 10 15 years ago yeah i mean i
think that's from a female perspective
though because as men get older they get
more options because they make more
money typically fair enough so and like
if you if you look at the data off of
dating apps like
it kind of drops off after like 45 for
women in general
and um
a lot of times like the girls that do
find love it's because they're being
realistic and they're saying i don't
need the eights nines and tens anymore
so you just say they get humbled with it
kind of thing yeah i think girls get i
mean would you would you guys agree that
like as men like older women start to
get humbler yeah oh yeah yes
absolutely
it's not even a bad thing like
they just end up they just realize that
they realize
where they're at and like what they need
is growth
they'll go for the guy that isn't as
good looking but has great character
right yeah
whereas
the younger women won't value the
character as much but they'll look at
how does this guy make me feel at this
moment in time
that's what i want oh is that why you
you mentioned feelings the feelings are
like 20 and they don't really matter
like in terms of growth they would
realize that i would look right that
makes sense i think as homeless gets
closer and closer
they'll start to
compromise on what they wanted rather
than be on the streets when you're
retirement or alone
regarding like elder women um
you know in my experience i think as i
transitioned from like say 12 13
up until you know like being a fully
grown adult
i know it's like the kind of
pre-pubescent
uh
like the pre-pubescent version of me
when looking at say young women say
maybe in their 20s like yourselves
um at that age prepubescent oh i'm just
a sweet kid walking down looking at
looking at a 20 year old
uh 14 15 started getting facial hair now
i'm like a threat
i'm this potential like rapist you
know great oh great great
my bad excuse me
um
but then uh
you know say if i'm looking at uh
a woman in their 40s or their 50s
at the age of 12 or at the age of 18
they addressed me and looked at me or
communicated with me in the exact same
way they just treated me like
you know whereas the 20 year old girl i
feel as though is just more
she has to protect herself more because
she gets so much more attention
bad good just attention in general
so in in the process of batting away bad
attention
she might be just like
batting at like perhaps a good
well-intended 15-year-old that's just
staring or like a well-intended guy that
has the right intentions that's trying
to approach respectfully but she's had
all of this kind of disrespectful
approaches in the past so she's gonna be
like no thank you
i don't want to hear it
um
she's also got options
absolutely so like she does she doesn't
have to
even vet doesn't have to entertain she
doesn't have to entertain it she
absolutely loves you because she's got
options that she likes that um she's
probably got guys four guys she's
talking to two guys that are probably a
bit serious um she's got options so
but with those options as you're
juggling i feel like the more balls
you're juggling the more stressed you
become
and the more difficult it is to make a
decision and commit to one particular
person men and women are different sure
they are of course there so what you may
find stressful and um
like multitasking for example you may
see that men are not as great as
as women are yeah for those men out
there that can talk to four or five
different girls at the same time
i think most i think most guys yeah
those guys do not know yeah no i mean no
it's a
it's a small percentage of guys that can
is what i mean
it's 20 or less i would argue probably
like five to five to ten percent of guys
actually can juggle and have the
opportunity to juggle multiple women
yeah i don't know how you do it i
honestly choose a stressful life
but um
yeah but i don't think they got time
it's
unemployed no it's not even time for
leads
girls make themselves very available to
guys of a certain status and caliber and
good looking absolutely so if a girl is
really attracted to a guy she's going to
jump through freaking hoops they like to
do it all off the top of your head think
of a story of a girl that was jumping
through hoops to get to a guy that
did not give a [ __ ] about her at all
and so it's not even that time consuming
for those guys because he cannot text
her back for two days and she'll still
be there at 1am when he needs her
so it's like it's like he doesn't have
to manage their relationship because
she's she's down bad mm-hmm
that's right i think it's um it's
difficult though like when you're
dealing with this kind of dynamic
um
i think a lot of people kind of get
confused i think a lot of young women
they're like why can't i get the ten if
he'll like say if he'll have sex with me
he'll take me out on dates i don't get
it why like who the girl or the guy yeah
yeah the girl the girl the girl's
confused why the guy will well like yeah
exactly i think a lot of women there's a
difference between relationship
attention and sexual attention
absolutely a guy will a guy will sleep
with
but if a guy hasn't slept with someone
in a while and he's nine he literally
might sleep with a four because she's
there and like i've heard guys say
things like it's better than my hand
[Laughter]
about about a woman and and if you bat
too high you're you're literally the
girl that's the the person that says
like
you're literally just better than his
hand that's how he feels
and do you think women are able to kind
of make that differentiation between
sexual attention and
like roma like genuine romantic i think
girls honestly in my experience yeah
they we just ignore the signs
like like it's like girls you could say
like your friends can sit her down and
say look this man does not care about
you
he is only using you for sex like he
does not want you in any way shape or
form and she'll say but he was so nice
to me when you talk to me at 2 a.m
you don't understand he's different
around me
but it's like like the writing will be
on the wall but you just can't
you can't it's like because we operate
on our emotions yeah i feel like some
girls i don't want to say that
delusional but like i feel like
again with
i don't yeah again i don't know if it's
they feel like that if it's in that
moment like like you said oh like i
don't know he makes me feel different at
2am like i don't know maybe
she hasn't
i don't know i think it goes back to
like feelings
do you know what i mean i feel like
she's she's thinking i feel like she's
thinking more of him than
of herself
yeah like i don't know it's just well
actually i could tell you there's
there's a um a chemical that women
release when they orgasm
no i'm serious so and it bonds you to
the guy in a way that like he's not
bonded to you
and so if a guy if a guy have you
how many times have you heard the word
dignitized oh yeah yeah yeah and that's
why it's because we're releasing a
chemical that they don't release
so men they bond you through loyalty and
like quality time
and so a girl can sleep with a guy have
the best sex of her life and like she's
attached where the man is like oh that
was better than my hand
[Laughter]
ish have you ever had a girl that's just
obsessed with you yeah
did she jump through the hoop what did
you do
what did she do she made herself
available
yes yeah yeah i'm
yeah
i can't even talk about that on the
stream still is she watching
who knows she's still obsessed
no no no we have to yeah cut that one
loose
[Laughter]
um i'm gonna read some more super chats
okay
so
there's yes
actually i'm gonna read it from top to
bottom okay correct me if i'm wrong
however we don't see this epidemic of
women not wanting to settle in islam why
is that what is that commuting we don't
see this epidemic of women not wanting
to settle in islam what is that
community doing differently passionate
rebellion there's no such thing as
settling you get what you can get
if what you can get is considered
settling your ego is too big maury let
lol we compare dying alone homeless to
being with a man that isn't attractive
this is man
freudian slip laws where women get fifty
percent of a man's assets assets were
enacted during the great depression
there was an unfull unfounded fear of
men abandoning their families not my
real name the purpose of marriage is not
personal happiness the purpose of
marriage is to build a family and
cultivate the next generation of society
asians understand this hence less
divorce without religion they call
patients
maury modern men don't want to wait
anymore because we know that you'll bust
it right open for on the first date for
the guy you truly desire johnny smith
emotions are empirical commitment and
duty aren't why are women insistent on
using fleeting emotions to make
permanent life choices and when you get
mad and then and why do you get mad at
men for your dumb choices um most
attractive women would rather deal with
drug dealers and scammers that's why
young men portray delinquent behaviors
even if they're raised right
read the super chats better and slower
complete the thoughts
i'm doing the customers
you're doing well you're doing well
that's the last one oh okay
can i address the one about you know
islam what what muslim women are doing
differently like um i think because i
think
people need to understand that they're
it's not that
you know muslim people are immune to
greater divorce rates or anything like
that but like i said before the
introduction of family it's not just you
know two people coming together they've
got their own little circle although yes
you do have that union and it's just you
two but it is like two tribes coming
together do you know what i mean it is
that uh fundamentally
i think that allows for a greater
success in marriage because
where
a child is involved like the western
nuclear family
has a great deal of trouble taking care
of children i personally believe that it
takes a village to raise a child
i had i was lucky enough to
you know have unfortunately my
grandfather passed before i was born but
my grandma
was like the leader of
my family the extended family
you know she's the son and everyone
orbits around her that's how it goes you
know i'm saying and
you know like
the my sister or my cousin sister she's
lived with us for 10 years grew up with
her may as well be my sister just got
married and you know she was with
her man for like five six years before
she introduced him to the family that's
you know not what you're supposed to do
from the muslim perspective
but
uh despite that being the case
that that time that those two families
had together was so important in
establishing whether these two people
are right for each other
having that time because the family your
families know you better than your
friends do and they know you better than
like your partner does so
i think vetting a girl through her
family is very important and it's like
same with the guy so i could see why
that would be helpful before we keep
going i'm going to read the final two
super chats that i missed um one drop i
feel isn't that the problem
just human pearl with facts and bring
that i put down i just put your down
wait pearl with facts that just that
bring that i just put down your puppy
energy
oh yeah
um
okay so question for you guys would you
guys consider yourself um would you
consider yourself a feminist
i just don't like putting myself in a
label
i agree a lot with the feminist movement
but
yeah i don't like labels and i feel like
feminism has kind of slightly been
hijacked by radical feminists and i
think any extreme of any
i don't know organization or movement
is bad i think extremes are bad and i
feel like
yeah i just feel like i have my beliefs
i don't need to attach a label to them
personally so yeah okay what about you
guys
i agree with you yeah yes
i don't think there's any
thing to really add on like before she
said to before okay
so do you guys think that radical
feminists have taken over feminism
high key yeah
at least in society's view of what
feminism is
i think a lot of people don't understand
where why feminism started in the first
place and then what the core values of
art of feminism
um
yeah that's kind of so why why would you
say it started in the first place and
what are the core values from my
understanding of feminism um i
understand that it started from women
wanting the right to vote that's okay
okay i know of it okay
and what about the core values
um
equality for men and women at least in
terms of
um
kind of rights to vote i don't know if
it started i don't know if women could
work back then um
potentially
violence against women as well because i
know
up until what the 90s it was legal for a
man to
uh
grape a woman okay in their relationship
and thank you
thank you
nothing could happen to him
um so just stuff like that because i
personally believe that
men and women are different and i do
believe we should be treated equally but
we're not equal and i do understand that
in certain contexts we can't do we can't
be treated the same or certain things
aren't going to work the same for each
person but i believe in stuff in terms
of like pay
and um
sexual violence i don't know if i'd say
that um and stuff like that yeah we
should be treated the same and i feel
like there are a lot of double standard
society now so yeah do you what do you
guys feel like in 2022 we're fighting
for in terms of equality
because i know historically like we
wanted the right to vote which funny
thing is um the majority of women didn't
actually want the right to vote because
it meant you were enlisted in the draft
oh i didn't know that yeah no i didn't
know that for a while either i'm glad
and i mean if i had to be drafted or
give up my right to vote i would give it
up same
i don't even care about politics that
much anymore
i'm good
i'm not sure
what's the question again sorry in 2022
what do you think we need feminism for
are there any rights you feel like we
don't have
radio silence
i guess no
no obviously we can't think of anything
yeah so what is the the purpose of
feminism then if if there's nothing more
to uh achieve in terms of women's rights
well that's the thing i feel like it's
sorry i just feel like it's evolved now
into
i just yeah i think it's just been
hijacked a bit yeah i think like
this have been lost a bit like when
pearl was asking you guys uh do you
consider yourselves feminists like i
would genuinely consider myself a
feminist but in the context of gender
equality of outcome right
of sorry not outcome excuse me of
opportunity i should correct that
uh equality of opportunity means that
you know if a woman does want to be a
bricklayer she can go be a bricklayer
she does want to be a soldier she can go
be a soldier if a man wants to be a
nurse go be a nurse etc
but when it comes to
like
i think where the issue is now with
feminism is that it's become
a scapegoat for just miss handry
meaning like just hatred towards and i
think and i think we can see this with
the johnny depp and amber heard case
where feminism went too far
because if that happened to a man with
power money and influence how many
average men did that happen to number
one and number two she walked
she did all that i mean she's broke now
but she's not in jail
if a man chopped off a woman's finger
wow yeah where would he he would be in
prison
he would never get out
yeah but can i say like
you know where feminism has gone too far
perhaps yeah in uh it's misandry and so
on i also think that the quote-unquote
red pill also kind of
has taken
some hope from a percentage of men who
now in turn evolve into becoming
you know women haters and thinking ah
there's just nothing but hoes out there
whatever the woman only wants me for my
money or a woman who do you who do you
think is i i think of rolo tomasi as
like the father of the red pill would
you agree with that or disagree
um father of the right like when i when
i think of i i know there are some
people maybe before him that aren't
alive anymore i think um i've heard that
yeah i'm look i'm not some like red pill
scholar you know what i'm saying but um
there's one guy i think alexander grace
who i think is the person that i've
listened to
um
and i've found his uh content quite
informational he's regurgitating a lot
of um rolo tomasi's ideas yeah but i
don't see i don't see the red pill as
like making angry man-hating or women
hating men i see it as exposing men to
the reality that a lot of a lot of them
will not reproduce because they are not
qualified to sure as sad as that is but
i think a lot of men
take that information and they don't
think oh i need to rise up to the
challenge increase my value and go out
there and do what i need to do but yeah
that's the men's fault that's the men's
fault absolutely but i'm saying like the
red pill oh like every red pill channel
is self-improvement every like
i can't think of one that says get angry
at women
i think it's just i think it's just men
say oh i have to go make out a lot of
money there's certain men that that's i
call them the video game addicted and
like corn addicted
group of
group of men
and they they say oh i have to make a
lot of money to get a woman
i have to be attractive to get a woman i
have to get in shape
and they know that they don't have the
qualities to do it so they get mad
because they probably will die alone
because and that's not a whole it's not
a fun reality absolutely i think for
those people that have gone into that
mental mentality
you've put yourself into that mentality
if you're if you're really unattractive
there are things you can do to go from a
four to a five yeah or from a two to a
three you get jacked what percent of men
are in super good shape absolutely it's
not it's not the majority even as a
woman like
i want to say 50 of women are overweight
so if you get in really good shape
you're like in the top 20 of women like
statistically men it's similar
but i think you know maybe i shouldn't
conflate the red pill with uh men going
their own way and all that kind of stuff
but i do think that there is a a rise
within the man of sphere
like generally of just hatred towards
women in general i think we need to be
objective about gender dynamics how
you know
men and women are different how they're
similar whatever
but
i think we are
you know this this red the red pill
conversation the conversation that's
happening within like feminist circles
and so on i think it's just building a
greater divide and i think that's where
you are so important pearl because you
are inviting feminists to have an open
dialogue and so on like to bridge that
gap see i don't i think people just like
the divide is people being unhappy with
their their reality which for women is
they can't get the guys they want and
for men is a certain percentage of men
is they can't get anyone but i don't
necessarily think it's the red pill i
think the red pill just
exposes you to reality
and i do understand a little bit but i
think where you're talking about like
the angry
um like the divisive titles and stuff
yes
yeah it's kind of it's sad but it's kind
of the game with youtube that's the
thing the algorithm incentivizes that
stuff
yeah and and so i think sometimes people
lose the message with the title like i i
did a i did a show the other day which i
labeled like ladies let your man cheat i
don't want to be with a cheater i don't
think it's okay to cheat but the whole
conversation was cheating's different
for men and for women and would you give
up
monogamy if it meant you're getting 10k
a month
from from your guy a lot of girls say
you know what i can deal with that if
i'm getting enough money
and like that was the conversation but
if someone just looks at the title they
might think that i i seriously am
endorsing cheating
so you're thinking about it right
what
i think about i'm just 20k 30k
just keep on going okay
yeah
30k 30k a month nope a month
you get 30k you get 30.
i feel like that's sorry i feel like
that's so debatable because like
obviously you're getting a 20km off yeah
it's good yeah but like i'm going to be
the
so you get you get to um
discuss that it's like oh you can't
speak about outside no one can know if
people find out then it's just high end
it's like escorts high-end escorts
no no so these girls are beautiful and
their job their job is to stay clean
these are high-end escorts that's all
he's going to use occasionally here and
there no one's paying me to do that no
no no no he's paying you he you're his
wife right you're the girl on his arm
okay and the reason he's picking escorts
is so no one else on the planet will
know
but he he's a guy he likes sexual
variety here and there but these girls
are paid to shut their mouth and and
stay clean
and they're nothing it's just a hoe
there's there's there's nothing
long term the wife knows about it the
wife knows what this is a this is
there's a certain percentage of men that
this is normal to this is what they do
and the vowels don't mean
it doesn't it no no she agrees to it
because she's getting thirty thousand
dollars a month to live
so she's getting in a house she has kids
she gets to do what she wants she gets
to drive the car she wants she gets to
go on holidays and she doesn't ever know
like she doesn't she see like she
doesn't see it happen no would you be
okay with it if would you be okay with
it
yeah
men and women are different yeah they're
different
no of course i wouldn't right i'm just
i'm just saying men and women are
different 30ks you wouldn't don't put it
safe
yeah would you do it
okay
wait
yeah okay
40k
men are programmed to want to spread
their seed
they have a biological predisposition
yeah to want to do that and they can
make the choice in order to be with you
to not
but there's a certain percentage of guys
that have women so readily available
that they don't have to compromise
anything because there are girls that
will say you know what
i i can give up the monogamy because
this man is fine he is tall he he gives
me great sex and and i get 30k a month
why on earth like do i care if he sleeps
with a hoe every now and then there's
there's a group of women that want to do
that that's true yeah that's true like i
i don't think my heart could do nothing
i'm sorry
no no the money is that the money sounds
nice it does say
you wouldn't
you wouldn't have to work ever again
until you're 80. so every month i'll be
burning yeah
no no no
there'll be fire and then the money will
come boom
water
i might never know at the time but like
i know in general that it's definitely
can i mean
is it is it pickle it's a pickle you
don't think okay
it might not be birken bags i'm not
really a designer yeah i'm not designing
it but there's something that you want
maybe it's a car
maybe something that you probably never
in your life would be able to afford
being because you guys are dancers
that's not really a high-end career
so you marry this guy he you're super
attracted to him he is the perfect guy
it is just from time to time he steps
out but you will never know when it's
happening
and this sounds like some tristan
tristan going no no tristan no it's not
tristan thompson because tristan
thompson was hooking up with girls in
public
no one would know you know that he can
do it and that if he does do it
and if you do find out it's it's just
going to be an escort because that's
what you pay for you pay for
um you pay you pay basically that
they're clean and that no one finds out
that is their job
do you think women i think it's just
morals but i don't know
do you think women then care more about
the embarrassment that comes from yeah
yes absolutely a hundred thousand people
so you you care more about how other
people perceive your relationship than
the actual relationship itself sure i
mean the same way the same way if a girl
is disrespectful behind the scenes
to her man it's a different thing than
if she's
yeah disrespectful yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay okay that perspective like
totally men and women think differently
yeah right i mean i think but i'm saying
it's about the disrespect like publicly
yeah
wait are you sorry are you saying
women care more about what people think
of their relationship
no i'm not saying that i'm asking
whether
you would care more about how other
people perceive the fact that your man
has cheated on you or whether the fact
that your man has cheated on you what
what would be your priority but in your
head the fact that your man's cheating
on you is always there speaking to them
sorry the fact that your man's cheating
on you is always in your head so like
that's just going to be eating it away
at you whether he's doing or not the
fact that he can do it is just eating
away at you the whole relationship and
then that's just going to play yeah if
you don't mind me asking have you ever
been cheated on
no okay so it's very hard to scare me
it's very hard to have that kind of kind
of conversation because you don't know
what it's like what tends to happen is a
girl will leave
if she thinks she can do better
or get a man that of better value than
the man she's with however if she
doesn't think she can get any better
than him
she will figure out a way to make
probably make him feel bad but she will
stay
so then what comes into play is okay
stay at what cost
all right then
if i
can figure out a way that oh my man's
gonna cheat on me
but no one's ever gonna find out
i can live with that and i get money
cool because he's gonna do it anyway
some girls look at the mistress some
some girls look at the side piece as an
employee like that is how they think of
them like you were you were just the
host they were doing it that would be a
good way because
because you go mad
personally
like you said about the feelings thing
like if you
keep it on your personal thing you're
gonna go mad someone's dying
your mind is doing his thing with
someone else yeah it's gonna be hard for
you to think of this woman on the same
level as you yeah
yeah so
employee you're gonna see as an employee
then calm because it's just like okay
this is basically they're working for me
i mean
sort of yeah
some girl i mean i'm talking about
escorts but there's some side chicks
that do it for free
they just want that they just want to
thank you yeah but like as the wife you
get your name on the on the deed you're
on the life insurance you're you have
his children yeah where she's just
wife is mad because two deaths does pop
don't
those don't things don't matter anymore
because if this is an open marriage now
because what no no it's open it's not
going to be open it's going to be open
though because no one knows because it's
a contract mm-hmm what kind of silly
contract is days sorry
don't get me wrong though it
only applies to men of high value or
yeah like the average man cannot do that
who do you think you are of course not
exactly humble yourself
meow but also
do you see how you don't respect the
average man as well okay don't stand up
she says crazy because it's crazy
it's fair it's what you believe and it's
how you perceive him and that's
completely up to you but it could be
vice versa it's true
that's me like mama if my mom would look
at me like that he would be like what
are you doing
right but men and women are different
but they're different things
women are familiar for purity
what if someone what meant
by who though
so women are valued by men and men
seek the validation of other men
why does everything go back to men
because because because men run the
world god forbid
like they built the world we live in
and um it's it's unfortunate i mean i
don't even want to say it unfortunately
i'm very grateful they did that because
we couldn't do a lot of the things we do
today without it but
i mean it's just men's
as your value as a woman is based on at
least in the sexual marketplaces based
on what men want you unless you're gay
but that's like a different thing
have you ever heard the phrase um
every building you ever see was built by
a man every person you ever meet was
birthed by a woman yeah yes yes i like
that phrase a lot because it's just
nobody would be here without a woman
exactly no building would be without a
man yeah
but and why is that because of what we
need
we're all playing our role
yeah the rules because if it wasn't for
the man we wouldn't be
you know i'm saying
someone said they disagree i didn't see
who it was it was me so you don't think
then what would you disagree with i
don't remember
that men
men wonder what well just because they
because of what they build and what like
why why why do you say that men won the
world well because men occupy most of
the power positions and they run most of
the fortune 500 companies
they they're in all we don't have that
is true
i mean i will say i think
we're never given the choice exactly
we're never given the choice
in order to get to those positions
because men are always there to
oh no that is that is
oh my gosh no you could you guys are all
capable of being a fortune 500 ceo i
just doubt many of you i agree with that
i just don't want to yeah you just don't
want to most women don't want to they
want to have kids and start a family
like
high end lawyers right so there's a law
firm in canada and they they wanted to
get there
they could not keep their high-end
lawyers after the age of 35 because they
could not pay those women enough to stay
because in order to get to those
positions positions you have to work 80
90 hour hour weeks
sounds terri i don't want to do that
but there's nothing do you think there's
something stopping us
well in the sense of like
i guess it all goes back to our role is
to have kids and have a and raise the
family but like
why do we have to raise the fat but
obviously we have the kids so we have to
raise family but like why is you you
talk about what is it compromise
cooperativeness cooperation so
where is the the splitting of the roles
where the man takes time off as well to
raise those kids and the women can carry
on with her career and everything so
they're both rising at similar levels so
we have the choice to do that it's just
i think
we don't want to
most women i mean i don't know about you
but if i had kids i would hope to stay
home with them for the first five years
and i think as women we just have more
of a natural inclination to to want to
be with our children yeah i mean when
you i just think when
mothers have a specific bond to their
child that it's not the same for men
yes just yeah nature
like if i if i'm really sad and
emotional like i always want to go to my
mom
don't give me and i respect how like
everyone on my channel will tell you
that i talk so highly of my dad but if
i'm gonna cry like i want to go to my
mom
and that's just i don't know i think
women have a different bond with their
children yeah
[Music]
yeah let me personally if um if i were
ever blessed to have a child
don't get me wrong i would love to stay
at home
i would love to just if i had the money
to just stay at home and chill with my
kid
chill with my young one and watch him
grow watch him walk watch whatever
i would love to do that
but the reality is i know that as a man
it is my job to provide for my family if
i'm not providing for my family what's
the point sticking around with this kid
watching him grow up if i can't give him
what he needs do you know what i mean
and regardless of what people say
like there you can literally watch it
might be anecdotal but you can literally
watch like videos where there's a baby
in the middle dad on one side mom on one
side they're both like come here come
here kid come here oh yeah always go to
the mum not always
not always all right okay okay all right
maybe not always but the point the point
that i'm trying to make though is that
fathers are extremely important
and they need to be around in their
child's life like working 80 hours a
week like your father god bless him
but i'm sure you you might felt feel
like you missed out certain aspects
of having your childhood
[ __ ] i don't got college dad i'm
chilling yeah
i can hang out with this place
you know i mean um
but like what like that that time though
where you're watching the child grow
that's like such a
it's a magical time they're changing
every month
and
honestly as perhaps it's my temperament
perhaps i have a more feminine
temperament i feel a degree of jealousy
towards women that have the capacity to
just stay at home and be with that child
because don't get it twisted fathers
love their kids just as much as moms do
you know i mean
um ideally anyway
but
you know we have a duty that our purpose
is to provide for this family and that
means that we can't be at home all the
time
like that's the
that's the reality that's something that
i will have to face as someone that
would love to be a stay-at-home dad if i
had the money to do that
yes what are you thinking
i disagree okay yeah go ahead but this
is just a personal thing and you said
yours was a personal thing
i think men
um
if
given the opportunity most men sorry
yeah yeah um
to stay in the house and watch their
kids grow
after a few days
yeah they'd be itching to go they'd be
agreeing
i think if you forgot your purpose as a
man if you forgot your purpose if you're
giving up your purpose as a man you're
giving up your path like your whatever
it is that you do that gives you
fulfillment the thing that allows you to
provide for your family if you're going
to forego that just to stay at home
then yeah i agree you will get an itch
because you've you've given up your
purpose what about what about if you
have no purpose you think you're a man
you should have one
so you're i've just i've just found that
like masculine men that are like driven
and ambitious
they cannot sit still they cannot stay
home my dad if he was a stay-at-home
father
he would kill us
he would hate it one because he'd be
yelling at us like why aren't you
working
and and two like you you could not pay
that man to stay home and do nothing
he's retired now he hated he did it for
like six months and then he just started
another company because like
those type of men cannot sit still they
have to be doing something
and women it's just not the same like we
stay-at-home moms are one like have some
of the highest rated happiness
right
like we we get fulfillment out of our
children i don't know men and women are
different i would imagine that it's not
the same for stay-at-home dads that like
they aren't as i don't i don't i haven't
seen numbers
my intuition is telling me it's it's
probably not yeah yeah i think men
generally find a greater fulfillment in
their purpose that which the purpose
being whatever it is that they do that
gives them fulfillment and allows them
to provide for their family right
whereas for
uh women
i think it's their generally their
interpersonal relationships their family
their community their immediate
community yeah
they find fulfillment in engaging with
that in a meaningful way
yeah no i agree
um
i'm going to read some super chats real
quick
um
if you checked your i don't know if the
chat got locked off
oh my gosh you okay
okay okay the chat the chat got locked
off
and um
i don't know if it's on stream as well
is your chat active there's a mosquito
um let's see okay you guys
i need you to sit still all right sorry
there's a mosquito no i can i the super
chats are showing for me
okay um
okay so just human i don't think boss
babes actually have a problem with a man
i think their real problem is with
nature nature makes them more hormonal
limits them during pregnancy bonds them
to children men aren't holding them back
nature is sentience why can't the women
keep working in the man raise the kids
because a majority of women loathe
bearing the financial burden regardless
of time
if a woman out earns her man she will
grow to resent him and leave
if um
dc oh dec
a woman don't if women don't shape up
the sex robots with ai and development
will be our future wives in 20 years in
an artificial womb we are good info
vader a bearded guy there's a difference
between someone who acknowledges the
truth from the red pill and a guy who
couldn't swallow it it's unfortunate the
loud minority are noticed but give the
wrong message
matt butcher all of this is further
proof it's not worth the effort guys put
relationships way down on the list of
five priorities and focus on success in
other ways sentience red pill versus
feminists one will tell you what the
what the men want and deals with in
reality the other tells you
what you should do and demand for men
otherwise it perpetuates misandry and
coddles women's feelings look at the
fallout from the a amber heard trial
just human red pill rage is very real
for a lifetime you were told the women
want you to be nice and work hard and
eventually a woman will appreciate you
this is a big driver of angry men
i am hollow there is no need for
feminism in 2022. in terms of the law
and equal opportunity we have that in my
opinion is rather damaging to women as
it perpetuates falsehoods that women
contri that contributes to women's
unhappiness the uk economist the
cost-benefit analysis is clear and the
high risk in divorce is too risky as the
as the higher earner is punished laws
must change and reflect equality
evan freshwater knowing female nature is
not hate evan freshwater feminism always
was always about and led by the radicals
aqua i won't take the chance of a woman
marrying me for the wrong reasons when
they hit the wall therefore i won't date
a woman over 28. i know many successful
guys who have this fear and think this
way um
sig si slg saucer 25
i am astonished that these women seem to
believe that they are entitled to
everything life has to offer as a man i
never felt entitled to anything
um
and then i think let me refresh the page
and just make sure but i think that's
all of them now zentian sent one in um
another one okay yeah
um brian ailman covet hit when my son
was three months old i got to spend the
next year working from home and getting
to spend time with him every day to see
him grow while it was absolutely amazing
i couldn't have done it if i wasn't
working sentience the bearded person
because you have yet to become a man you
do have a feminine temperament you're
not designed you're not designed to
nurture you are the force of will which
for forges your legacy into an adult
iron shapes iron um dragon stallion 101
dude who wants to stay home with the kid
the wife will see him as effeminate and
will be turned off and she will lose
interest in him
divorce here you come
and is there anything after that or we
got them all thank you
okay um well guys i think this was a
really good show um i really appreciate
you guys all being really good sports um
i think you guys were very entertaining
so i appreciate it one more super chat
oh one more super chat
um
hold on i gotta refresh it on my page
real quick okay
boy type the sex box bots cannot come
fast enough
um okay and albert retro okay i don't i
don't know what y'all doing with that
don't don't involve that with my channel
um request in light of the new thor
movie is it possible for you to do a
show on male victims of essay being
mocked in pop culture yeah i actually
that's a good idea i definitely can do
that
um but back to what i was saying you
guys are really good sports i thought
you were very entertaining and fun to
have on we would love to have you back
in the future
why don't we go around plug any social
media you want to plug
and any final thoughts that you guys
have
so then you can start and go around this
way um okay uh as far as social media um
you can get my instagram handle is
t-h-a-i-s underscore a-k-a-n underscore
um in terms of final thoughts
uh thank you for having me on the show
it was really fun it's the first podcast
i've ever done
i thought the questions were really good
because it actually
opened my mind up a bit to some points i
may have not considered or didn't even
know about
um and i would say the most
kind of
expansion i've got today is i actually
don't think there is a place for
feminism in 2022.
i actually do you've had so many girls
sit look at that
yeah for socials um my instagram is five
underscores and then justice and then
there's five other schools on the other
side
and in terms of final thoughts it made
me really
open-minded on all the all the
discussions that we've had in terms of
feminism
in terms of relationships and feelings
and all sorts that we've spoken about
and yeah with the feminism a hundred
thousand percent yes
me
okay
um
yeah you guys can have my install which
is underscore
nano so n a n a dot ldn
and um yeah thank you for having me in
the show as well yeah thanks for coming
um
my final thoughts
ah just
choose young people wisely yeah yeah
choose the people wisely and see like it
really open my eyes to actually see
what they actually want i feel like men
don't really get to
talk about what they actually really
want even though sometimes they might
show it in the beginning or might not
but
just communicate that's what i got from
this yeah yeah communication definitely
is
the biggest thing that i think i've
gained and being able to talk to you
guys and hear your guys's opinions about
this topic has really opened my mind as
well
and thank you for having us on the show
it's been really good
thank you for coming my insta is vegan
dot underscore dot tegan t-e-g-a-n
thank you so much
oh guys they're they're dancers they're
not strippers i'm just putting this
like real dancers
go ahead go ahead who said that
they said are they strippers
right now okay
okay
look final thoughts um firstly it was
it's really been a pleasure speaking to
you girls pearl uh ish and obviously
fury's been quiet but it's been a
pleasure
to
appreciate you guys having me um
uh instagram is done him at than him so
that's t a underscore him h-i-m
um final final thoughts
i would probably say like specifically
to men i can't i can't say much you know
to women i'm not a woman i can't really
advocate like that but i would say
to men like
find a set of principles moral or
otherwise
stick to them
find a purpose
and grind
and really really grind
like
go after it
and be
you know an honorable patriarch of your
family go out there do that that's it
thank you
um
my
my insta is uh
horse1 if you want to follow me but um
yeah thank you again to pearl thank to
all the ladies for showing up um it's
been really just eye opening and
i'd say i'm
[Music]
more convinced that feminism is a like
perpetuating this idea that there's
something else than that we need in life
other than to have families and children
and just work together i think that's
all that we need i don't think we i
don't think women need to have high
payed higher paying jobs i don't think
men need to cow down to women or
anything like that i think we need more
to go back to what we used to be as
people
and that's all i have to say but thank
you everyone it's been great
thank you all for coming you're all very
entertaining um we'll definitely have
you guys back again i'm gonna read a
couple more super chats that we had
um i think there's one or two i really
appreciate you guys donating because
again we're trying to save for multiple
camera angles in here so all the super
chats are going towards the cameras um
so i just want to make sure that i'm
reading them all um william barnes all
of civilization is an attempt to repair
a faulty part that didn't want to work
as soon as men invent invent
the artificial room that womb that part
will finally be replaced women will go
extinct and mankind will be better for
it
okay william wow
i think you're being a little dramatic
yes
i think you're being a little down in
the comments might be
um okay women are but thank you for the
super chap yes
i will read it um
am women are equal to men seconds later
freaks out from an insect okay
[Laughter]
exciting voices
exciting show exciting show
um tomorrow we are doing a 24 hour live
stream red pilling women for 24 hours to
hopefully celebrate getting to 100k
so if you guys want to see me
die of exhaustion on camera
and red pill women for 24 hours tune in
9pm tomorrow till 9pm friday
don't forget to like this video on your
way out subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell sign up for
memberships for exclusive behind the
scenes content and we will talk to you
next time bye